Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Interessierst du dich noch für Politik? Ein bisschen. Willst du dein Humor wiederfinden?
Humor ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht.
Das stimmt, Humor ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht. Und wir haben das letzte Mal schon gesagt, wir möchten uns über die CDU lustig machen. Und zack, haben wir so ein Angebot bekommen, dass uns heuristisch dann doch einiges da liegt.
Wird der Autor froh sein, wenn wir sein Buch, das so seriös ist, so einleiten? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ist Professor für Transformation der Demokratie an der Universität Wien, Fabio Wolkenstein, und hat dieses Buch geschrieben, in die dunkle Seite der Christdemokratie, Geschichte einer autoritären Versuchung. Und wir starten den Podcast. Und eben noch hat bei Twitter unsere Hörerin Nicole darauf hingewiesen, dass sich Merz mit Lindsay Graham trifft. Auch da möchte man ein gutes Netzwerk unter Konservativen wohl herstellen. Und über Lindsay Graham habe ich ja im vergangenen Podcast noch gesprochen, der dann davor warnte, was Chris Maltz da macht, das sei ganz gefährlich, das sei eine ganz schlimme Radikale, die jetzt da Gewerkschaften gründen wollen und dass man den Menschen es nicht gönnt, dass sie einfach mal ein erfolgreiches Unternehmen aufgebaut haben. Also das ist die Denkweise von Lindsay Graham. Der trifft jetzt auf Friedrich Merz.
Genau, Lindsay Graham kennen wir ja als erbitterten, erboßen Kämpfer gegen Donald Trump, bis er plötzlich Präsident ist und dann ein Speichelecker und Arschgriecher. Man kann es nicht anders sagen, sondern das Gleiche. Also solche 180 Grad Wenden. Es sind unglaublich Biografien bei Merz ja auch, die dann bei solchen Treffen aufeinandertreffen. Und wir wissen, da findet auch immer so Entourage-Begegnung statt. Also da wird irgendwie genetztwerkt und so. Ja, genau, es ist auf der einen Seite so düster und auf der anderen Seite bietet es sich wirklich an mit einer eigenen Fragestellung. Deswegen ja, wir wollen den Fabio Wolkenstein, ich gehe die Autoren immer so ein bisschen drüber hinweg, also Fabio Wolkenstein, wollen wir natürlich nicht hier ein Anliegen, ein Ziel, eine Methodik des Buchs unterstellen, die nicht drin steckt. Aber da wir oder ich so eine Fragestellung habe, können wir uns lustig machen über die CDU. Ja, können wir. Und dieses Buch bietet Material, auch wenn es das vielleicht nicht wollte. Es ist ein bisschen so, bei Fabio Wolkenstein muss man noch dazu sagen, der ist halt Österreicher, der arbeitet auch in Österreich. Deswegen hat er so einen europäischen Blick, weil ihm Österreich nicht reicht. Es ist nicht so spezifisch deutsch, wie man erwartet, wenn man in Deutschland dieses Buch liest.
Nein, es ist aufgezeigt, und das ist, glaube ich, schon das sehr Lehrreiche für Deutsche, wie viele konservative Parteien es gibt, wie die miteinander zusammenhängen, wo sie divergieren, denn wir haben ja einen ohnehin unglaublich auf die Bundespolitik ausgerichteten Blick. EU interessiert uns immer nur so am Rande. Wenn, dann gucken wir lieber nach Amerika. Und hier erfahren wir aber dann einfach mal, welche Linien es da gibt in der österreichischen, konservativen Politik. In Italien auch, da liest man ja so ganz wenig drüber. Man hat dann immer diese Berlus-Kroni-Ära mitbekommen, aber was war eigentlich davor? Oder das ist dann vielleicht besonders wichtig, dass hier noch mal einiges zu Orban zu lesen ist.
Genau. Und dieser, fangen wir mal bei Orban nur kurz an, um so diesen Rahmen zu schlagen. Also Orban ist eine rechte Partei. Die ÖVP arbeitet mit einer rechten Partei zusammen. Also sie hat mit der FPÖ koaliert. Und in Deutschland grenzt sich die CDU immer noch ab von rechten Parteien. Das ist ganz wichtig zu sehen, dass wir hier in Deutschland aufgrund unserer Geschichte so ein bisschen anderes Verständnis von Christdemokratie haben, als es schon in anderen Ländern gelebte politische Praxis ist. Weshalb dieser Untertitel Geschichte einer autoritären Versuchung, autoritären Versuchung sowieso fast schon stehender Begriff mittlerweile beim Blick auf solche Parteien. Heidmeier und so hat ja auch 2018 dazu geschrieben. Und man kann es als größeres Problem aus dem Text herauslesen, als wir es in Deutschland fühlen, weil wir relativ, also wir haben so ein Grundvertrauen irgendwie, dass die CDU schon nicht mit der AfD zusammenarbeitet. Und da muss man immer dazu sagen, bis sie es dann doch tut in irgendwelchen Landkreisen oder wo auch immer in Thüringen, sich solche Sachen dann irgendwie Stimmengemeinschaften ergeben und so. Von daher steckt ja so ein gewisser Alarmismus und eine thematische Problematisierung drin, die uns doch interessieren sollte, da die CDU eben gerade auch wieder auf Orientierung ist und wir nicht genau wissen, wohin führt denn das eigentlich? Wenn sie jetzt so ein Bollwerk aus Scholz und FDP, vielleicht verstehen die sich ja noch mal besser in drei Jahren. Scholz und Lindner verstehen sich ja ziemlich gut. Vielleicht hacken die irgendwas aus. Jetzt so einen politischen Kampf zu führen, der die Aufmerksamkeit zieht, das haben wir ja, das hat ja die CDU-These schon.
Eigentlich will Lindner die Ampel verlassen und tut jetzt alles dafür, dass er rausgedrängt wird und das ist dann so was wie Neuwahlen. Gibt und dass man jetzt sagt, man hat jetzt eine gute Stimmung. Die SPD ist erneut geschwächt dank auch der Grünen, die so auf Scholz eingehackt haben. Also das muss man auch hier nochmal ganz klar unterstreichen. Und dann wäre die Möglichkeit für eine schwarz-gelbe Koalition ohne vielleicht sogar noch einen weiteren Koalitionspartner.
Genau solche Kalküle sehen wir, müssen wir, können wir nicht ausblenden. Und dadurch wissen wir aber nicht genau, wohin bewegt sich dann. Nun gut, das Buch beginnt mit dem christdemokratischen Auftrag und Geschichte, Aushöhnung nach dem Krieg. Ja, aber Hinweis, es gibt eben auch dunkle Seiten. Wenn wir an die Christdemokratie denken in Deutschland, sagt er, ja, das ist so die Aushöhnung mit den Kriegsparteien und das Wirtschaftswunder. Und ja, stimmt, diesen Haken kann man irgendwie groß dran machen, aber es gibt eben auch die dunkle Seite der Christdemokratie. Auch in Deutschland. Und gleich zu Beginn notiert er eben, dass dieses Buch wahrscheinlich den Christdemokraten, die es lesen werden, nicht besonders gut gefällt. Würde ich sagen, ja, das stimmt wahrscheinlich. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir immer wieder, immer wenn du über Ideologie sprichst, zuletzt ganz explizit bei Corporate Therapy, Menschen machen Filme und wissen selber nicht, welche Ideologie sie gerade breiten. Menschen machen gerade Karriere in der CDU und wissen selber nicht, welchen ideologischen Traditionen sie ausgeliefert sind. Und für die ist so ein Buch auch wahnsinnig hilfreich, nochmal in den päpstlichen Texten, Enzyklikas und so weiter, wirklich das dargelegt zu bekommen, wo das kollektive Denken, dem sie gerade ausgeliefert sind, weil sie eben auch irgendwelche Satzungen mit ändern und so, da einfach mit leben, mitbestimmen. Also in der Ansicht ist es für angehende CDU, Politiker vielleicht auch ein interessantes Lehrbuch, habe ich mir dann so gedacht, zwischendurch, dass man da mal mit dem...
Ja, es leistet ja eine ideengeschichtliche Aufarbeitung und dann kann man wissen, wo man sich verortet oder nicht. Und vieles ist ja Intuition bei diesen CDU-Politikern, das haben wir auch immer mal wieder gesagt, worauf sie so reagieren. Aber dem Ganzen liegt schon auch ein Weltbild zugrunde. Und das ist jetzt diese interessante Überlegung. Wir wissen gerade aus der CDU, es gibt sehr viele, die einfach sehr clevere Machtpolitiker sind und die auch eine große Anpassungsfreude entwickeln, sobald sich eine Machtoption ergibt. Wir konnten das auch bei Kurz zum Beispiel beobachten in Österreich. Aber die These von Wolkenstein ist schon, dass es so etwas wie eine ideologische Grundlage oder Essenz gibt. Diese aber wiederum ist sehr weit gefasst. Also man scheut sich davor, eine Programmatik zu formulieren. Man schreibt nicht wie die Linkenmanifeste, wo man sich dann sehr sklavisch dran halten müsste und wo es dann zu diesen Spaltereien kommt. Das ist ja etwas, was man den Linken immer vorwirft oder was man auch diagnostizieren kann, dass es diese Spalterei gibt, dass man sagt, das ist aber nicht mehr der leninistische Weg, das ist nicht mehr der marxistische Weg. Und was hat eigentlich der Späte Engels dazu gesagt? Diese Fragen stellen sich bei Konservativen in dieser Weise nicht. Und das ist rückgebunden an das Christentum. Und damit ist primär das katholische Christentum gemeint. Die Protestanten kommen aber dann auch nach 45 da mit rein. Das schafft man auch sehr erfolgreich. Aber zunächst mal, wenn man ins 19. Jahrhundert geht, dann ist die Frage, wie positioniert sich die Kirche überhaupt zu so etwas wie Demokratie? Das wird lange Zeit abgelehnt, verteufelt. Der Papst öffnet sich dann erst später dafür. Aber diese Grundlage, die christliche, ist die katholische. Und ein Katholik würde jetzt, ein sehr frommer würde mir sagen, naja, diese Unterscheidung, die ich jetzt mache, zwischen Christentum und Katholizismus, ist ja ein Unsinn, weil Katholizismus ist Christentum und Christentum ist Katholizismus. Also da sieht man es schon. Und außerdem bedeutet katholisch allumfassend. Und das meint auch, dass aufgehoben sind darin die Widersprüche. Das, was wir eigentlich gar nicht so verstehen können, wie kann es sein, dass das und das unter dem Mantel katholische Kirche formiert? Und genauso ist es aber auch bei den Christdemokraten, dass man einen Norbert Blüm hat, einen Heiner Geissler, einen Friedrich Merz und auch einen Söder, der jetzt mit den Grünen bereit ist zu flirten, der aber auch vor zwei, drei Jahren Orban empfängt und ihm den Franz-Josef Strauß-Preis noch überreicht.
Genau. Und der Gabriel in Schleswig-Holstein und der Wüst in Nordrhein-Westfalen machen, ist ja genauso. Die haben ja Wahlkämpfe geführt, wo sie nicht festgenagelt werden konnten. Und ich finde, der Wolkenstein macht das ganz hervorragend, am Anfang uns darauf hinzuweisen. Einfach, wir sind schon politisch interessierte Menschen. Und du hast jetzt viele Namen genannt, Geißler und so weiter. Wie passen die eigentlich alle so da rein? Blüm noch so als Überzeugungstäter mit sozialpolitischem Gewissen irgendwie und dann aber jetzt so dieses völlig neutrale, wir können alles da reinpacken in so eine Person. Hauptsache die Macht ist irgendwie gesichert und so. Jetzt sind sie in der Opposition, also auf Suche. Und als politisch interessierter Mensch, und man verfolgt Politik nochmal anhand so von Personenkarrieren, nimmt er uns dann nochmal sozusagen zurück, hebt uns so über die Wolken und lässt uns nochmal über das ganze Panorama der letzten 150 Jahre fliegen und sagt eben, wir sehen am Beispiel der ÖVP, am Beispiel der Fides und so weiter, die grundsätzliche Frage, die wir uns stellen, ist wie stehen die Christdemokraten zur Demokratie? Und ich finde, das ist eine sehr mutige Frage, denn es sind Christdemokraten, die, und es sagt er ausdrücklich, wir in unserer Welt verbinden mit dem Zuständen, in dem wir leben. Also die Wende, Helmut Kohl war Kanzler und hat irgendwie alles ganz gut gemanagt. Wir sind jetzt eine friedliche Welt, die den Kalten Krieg überwunden hat. Das Wirtschaftswunder, ein Zigarren rauchender Wirtschaftsminister, dem das einfach eingedichtet wird, das Wirtschaftswunder verursacht zu haben, wird dann nach Kanzler und wir sind alle zufrieden damit. Konrad Adenauer söhnt uns mit den Kriegsparteien aus, auch CDU. Irgendwie wir leben in so einer Welt, die so im Hintergrund rauscht. Die CDU hat sich immer um uns gekümmert. Aber trotzdem stellen wir uns jetzt mal die Frage, wie stehen die eigentlich zur Demokratie und lassen eben offen, vielleicht haben die gar nicht so ein richtiges demokratisches Verständnis. Und dann kommt da, und das ist eigentlich interessant, dass wir auf der einen Seite praktischerweise so einer CDU-Welt ausgeliefert sind, in der wir heute leben. Gleichzeitig sind aber nur die anderen Parteien dadurch aufgefallen, dass sie so krasse Grundsatzprogramme haben. Gutes Berger Programm der SPD zum Beispiel. Oder die sozialliberalen Freiburger Thesen der FDP. Sowas finden wir bei der CDU eben ausdrücklich nicht. Sondern er schreibt dann, man tut der Christdemokratie nicht ganz unrecht, wenn man ihr den programmatischen Charakter abspricht. Und dann schreibt er nochmal pragmatisches, also was die CDU hat, ist ein pragmatisches und integratives Politikverständnis, das sich auf der Grundlage allgemeiner normativer Grundsätze rechtfertigen lässt, aber kaum in ein herkömmliches konzeptionelles Korsett zu zwängen ist. Was bedeutet, wenn die CDU 2022, in der die Welt in Aufruhr ist, in Oppositionen befindet und selber gerade auf der Suche nach sich selbst, können wir uns mal überraschen lassen, weil fast alles möglich ist. Diese Partei hat eine Geschichte, aber keine inhaltliche Tradition und dadurch droht, würde ich sagen, droht ist das richtige Wort, droht uns einfach alles demnächst. Wir wissen nicht genau, in welche Richtung Friedrich Merz geht, wo er Unterstützung witzert und die dann eben auch ausbeutet. Und das, finde ich ehrlich gesagt, ist ein super wichtiger Einschlag, einfach mal in so einem Thema, um wirklich mal große Fragen jetzt aufzuwerfen.
Ein gemeinsamer Punkt, der vielleicht doch alle Linien miteinander verbindet, die es da gibt, die antidemokratische Linie, die stark sozial bis ja so einer fast sozialistisch anmutenden Politik verschriebenen, also es ist kein Sozialismus. Und dann auch die Linien, die sich mit dem Wirtschaftsliberalismus gut verstehen. Dann wieder die antiliberalen Linien, die sagen, nein, das ist das große Problem der Wirtschaftsliberalismus. Diese Linien alle verbindet doch ein Antikommunismus. Also das ist quasi so das, wo man sich immer einig ist. Man definiert aber dann auch immer sehr neu, was Kommunismus ist. Also das geht ja dann bei einem Friedrich Merz sehr früh schon los. Ja, also eine Forderung nach mehr Lohn ist dann schon kurz vor Kommunismus natürlich. Und das ändert sich über die Jahre hinweg. Aber wir haben mit diesem Antikommunismus, also mit einer Haltung, so sind wir jedenfalls nicht, hat man einen gemeinsamen Punkt, der auch alles wieder eint, was dann auch dazu führt in der Geschichte, dass man zwar hin und wieder solche Stimmen zulässt wie ein Norbert Blüm oder einen Geißler, oder man hat diese Adenauer Rede von 1947, in der er eigentlich sagt, der Kapitalismus ist das große Problem. Das hat sich ganz deutlich jetzt gezeigt. Das ist da. Aber man hat dann auch einen Adenauer, der zugleich zarte Bande knüpft zu Franco, zu dem portugiesischen Diktator Salazar. Also all das ist auch möglich, weil man doch am Ende sich einig ist, könnte ein guter Verbündeter sein gegen den Kommunismus. Und diese Haltung zieht sich aber auch durch. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur die kalte Kriegshaltung, sondern das ist eigentlich eine vom 19. Jahrhundert herrührende Haltung. Denn der Papst ist es, der sehr früh erkennt, der Sozialismus ist die größte Bedrohung für die Kirche, für den Status quo, Marx ist das Problem. Und dann versucht man auf die eine oder andere Weise entweder dagegen zu schießen oder der marxistischen Bewegung den Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen, indem man selbst sagt, wir bieten hier zum Beispiel die katholische Soziallehre an.
Genau. Unter dieser Maßgabe, dass wir nicht genau wissen, was droht uns denn mit dieser CDU, die auf Suche ist, ist dieser Verweis auf 1947 wahrscheinlich der interessanteste, was unsere Frage ist, meine Fragestellung angeht, um dann auch das ganze Buch darunter zu lesen. Denn dieses Aalner Programm sagt Wolkenstein selber, ist gar nicht so relevant für die Geschichte der CDU, aber wir heben es trotzdem hervor, weil der Autor ist eben Konrad Adenauer, der maßgebliche Autor, 1947. Und da steht drin, das kapitalistische Wirtschaftssystem ist den staatlichen und sozialen Lebensinteressen des deutschen Volkes nicht gerecht geworden. Nur wenige Jahre später dreht sich das Schiff.
Lies doch noch die zwei Sätze weiter.
Ich habe mir nur die rausgeschrieben.
Okay, dann musst du mir die Seite gerade sagen. Ich finde es nämlich jetzt gerade nicht.
Also in voller Länge, also soweit, wie ich es mir notiert habe, du sagst dann, ob es in der Länge reicht. Das kapitalistische Wirtschaftssystem ist den staatlichen und sozialen Lebensinteressen des deutschen Volkes nicht gerecht geworden. Nach dem furchtbaren politischen, wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Zusammenbruch als Folge einer verbrecherischen Machtpolitik kann nur eine Neuordnung von Grund aus erfolgen. Inhalt und Ziel dieser sozialen und wirtschaftlichen Neuordnung kann nicht mehr das kapitalistische Gewinn und Macht streben, sondern nur das Wohlergehen unseres Volkes sein. Adenauer sagt das. 1947. Kurze Zeit später ist es aber plötzlich, also wir müssen nochmal genau fassen, 1947, Deutschland ist noch nicht gegründet, aber der Krieg ist seit drei Jahren vorbei. Man ist genau dazwischen und kommt plötzlich mit so einer sozialistischen Idee um die Ecke, irgendwie der Kapitalismus und so weiter hat irgendwie nicht weitergetragen. Und dann, nur wenige Jahre später, steht Adenauer da und unterstellt plötzlich den Marxisten, weil sie nämlich so eine materialistische Weltauffassung haben, dass sie eigentlich schuld sind an den Möglichkeiten, die Hitler dann genutzt hat, weil er auf ein Volk traf, das für diese materialistischen Vorstellungen irgendwie empfänglich war. So, wir haben also innerhalb weniger Jahre, als alle auf der Suche sind, was machen wir mit dieser Partei, mit dem Land und so weiter? Gibt es überhaupt eine Neugründung und so? Während alles in Gründung ist, sind es hier inhaltlich 180 Grad Hasenläufe über so ein Feld. Man wird gejagt von so einer Idee, man will zurück zur Macht, aber wie eigentlich? Und man weiß gar nicht gegen was man sich wendet und für was man sich ausspricht. Kreuz und quer gibt man allen die Schuld, außer sich selber, mit dem besonderen Verweis auf, und das ist dann auch wieder Adenauer, dass plötzlich der Wert, der individuelle Menschenwert, der Mensch selbst erst mal als Individuum erfunden wird und an ihn so eine Würde geknüpft wird. Das allerdings ist dann auch nicht wieder eine Idee gewesen, die irgendwie aus der CDU, wir haben so eine Erfahrung gemacht mit dem Holocaust und so weiter, wir müssen jetzt mal den Menschen einen Wert geben, sondern man bedient sich da einfach bei dem, was man vorfindet. Man findet einen Marxismus vor, man findet eine katholische Soziallehrer vor, man findet irgendwelche Enzyklika-Texte vor. Und dann ist mal der eine Schuld und dann ist mal der andere Schuld. Und Hauptsache, man findet irgendwie zurück zur Macht. Und wir wissen ja, ja, Adenauer hat dann als erster Kanzler ziemlich lange regiert. Also es droht sozusagen alles in orientierungslosen Zeiten.
Lass uns nochmal bei diesem Punkt bleiben, denn das ist ja eine ganz merkwürdige Sache. Wir haben jetzt aus dem Ahlener Programm diese Zeilen von dir gehört. Und dann denkt man, naja, das geht doch eigentlich in eine sehr gute sozialpolitische oder vielleicht sogar sozialistische Richtung mit ein bisschen katholischem Anstrich. Aber keineswegs entwickelt sich das hier so, sondern man hat dann genau das, was du eben beschrieben hast, dass man plötzlich einen Adenauer vorfindet, der sagt, ja, der Marxismus ist Teil des Problems gewesen, das wir hatten, und zwar basiert sowohl der Nationalsozialismus als auch der Marxismus auf einer materialistischen Weltanschauung. Und diese materialistische Weltanschauung hat uns ins Verderben geführt. Und wenn wir jetzt mal uns erinnern an diese Erika Steinbach Tweets und auch von Jungliberalen gibt es diese Tweets, aber es sind ja vor allem immer wieder Konservative, die es äußern, die sagen, Nationalsozialismus war ja Sozialismus. Also in dem Sinne, das war ja Marxismus. Dann ist ganz klar, woher diese Denkweise kommt. Und verknüpft wird das dann mit noch etwas, und das ist hochinteressant, nämlich, wogegen man sich dann auch wendet, ist nicht nur diese materialistische Weltanschauung, sondern auch der Staatsabsolutismus. Man arbeitet, man sagt eigentlich, man hat einen antitotalitären Auftrag. Es gibt ja auch eine große Arendt-Rezeption im Übrigen in der CDU. Das wird jetzt hier nicht thematisiert, aber das ist ja für CDU-Leute auch manchmal nicht unwichtig. Man sagt jetzt also, der Staatsabsolutismus verkörpert dann zum Beispiel durch Hitler, oder auch, wenn man von einem marxistischen Staat ausgeht. Das ist etwas, gegen das wir auch kämpfen müssen. Und wenn wir jetzt noch mal daran denken, dass wir immer mehr jetzt die Politiker auftreten sehen, wir hatten das besonders deutlich mit Lindner, der sagte, ich will nicht, dass die Taxonomie-Politik anfällig wird, dann ist das genau diese Idee, dass der Staat nicht zu mächtig werden darf dort. Dass man also versucht, sich davor zu befallen. Was aber zugleich wieder im CDU-Sinn bedeutet, natürlich dürfen wir in ein Spiegelbüro und da alle Journalisten filzen, wenn wir da ein Interesse haben. Es geht ja um Deutschlands Sicherheit. Also da darf der Staat dann plötzlich auch wieder autoritär werden. Und bei Adenauer heißt es ja dann, dass dieser Nationalsozialismus nichts anderes als eine bis ins Verbrecherische hinein vorgetriebene Konsequenz der sich aus der materialistischen Weltanschauung ergebenden Anbetung der Macht und Missachtung, ja Verachtung des Wertes Einzelmenschen. In einem Volk, das so erst durch die preußische, überspitzte und übertriebene Auffassung vom Staat, seinem Wesen, seiner Macht, den ihm geschuldeten unbedingten Gehorsam, dann durch die materialistische Weltanschauung geistig und seelisch vorbereitet war, konnte sich begünstigt durch die schlechte materielle Lage weiter Volkskreise verhältnismäßig schnell eine Lehre durchsetzen, die nur den totalen Staat und die willenlos geführte Masse kannte, eine Lehre, nach der die eigene Rasse, die Herrenrasse usw. Und was hier also stattfindet, ist, dass er sagt, wir können ein Angebot schaffen, die materialistische Denkweise zu überwinden. Und was damit aber eigentlich wiederum gesagt wird, und das ist ja so toll, dass man das auch immer wieder bei CDU-Leuten hört, gerade wenn es um Lohnforderungen oder so geht, man arbeitet doch nicht wohl nur, um Geld zu verdienen. Oder sowas wird ja dann gerne gesagt. Also man versucht jetzt so einen Wert des Menschen herzustellen, aber eigentlich versucht man jetzt, Bürgersubjekte zu produzieren, die nicht mehr wirtschaftlich primär denken, also die nicht sagen, ich möchte aber eigentlich mehr Lohn haben, sondern die sich zufriedengeben sollen mit dem, was sie haben. Denn egal wie viel du hast, du bist ja immer von uns mit diesem Wert oder dieser Würde ausgestattet. Und das ist wiederum Würde, etwas, was wir dann auch nochmal besonders definieren, gerade sowas Familienpolitik oder so anbelangt. Und damit hat man eigentlich Subjekte produziert, die nicht mehr materialistisch sind, in dem Sinne, dass sie etwas verlangen. Das ist eigentlich ein Kern. Und das ist ja auch das, was alle jetzt immer so deutlich machen in dieser ganzen konservativen Politik. Wir hatten es, wann immer die Zahlen aufgerufen wurden über Armut oder sonst was, dann wurde das ignoriert. Dann wurde einfach mal gesagt, ja, es geht darum, ein würdevolles Leben zu haben und, und, und. Aber nie hat man wirklich in einer materialistischen Argumentation mal darüber gesprochen.
Genau. Und das ist eine Lehre von heute. Diese ganze Hufeisen-Theorie-Diskussion. Warum kann ein moderner CDU-Politiker nicht einfach mal sich von rechts abgrenzen, ohne nicht gleich auch noch die linke Gewalt und so weiter zu thematisieren? Das steckt da ganz tief drin. Bei Adenauer, du hast jetzt gerade den Wortlaut Wolkenstein vorgelesen. Und kurz davor hat er ja dieses...
Nee, das war Adenauer selbst, was ich jetzt vorgelesen habe. Diese preußisch überspitzte und übertriebene Auffassung vom Staat. Das ist Adenauer selbst. Genau.
Na, ich habe hier noch ein Zitat. Das ist ganz interessant. Ich hoffe, wir doppeln uns jetzt nicht. Du hast es nicht eben auch schon vorgelesen. Aber 46, die menschliche Person, ihre Zitat, einzigartige Würde, der Wert eines jedes einzelnen Menschen ist unersetzlich. So, dann dieses Adenauer Programm. Auch zeitgleich 47. Adenauer irgendwie, also die kapitalistische Logik ist es ja nicht. Und da fragt man sich ja, welche denn dann? Weil dann bräuchten wir ja irgendwie, wenn wir uns nicht dem Markt ergeben wollen, ein Staate, das für uns organisiert. Und dann diese große Absage, wäre eine, dann Zitat, Wortlaut Adenauer, eine Zentralisierung der politischen und der wirtschaftlichen Macht in einem Staate oder bei einer Klasse anstrebt, bereite zwangsläufig den Weg der Diktatur, empfühlen und denken seine Anhänger vor, wenn schließlich auch ein anderer den so vorbereiteten Weg der Diktatur beschreitet. Also es gibt Wegbereiter für Hitler und die kann man durchaus dann auch im marxistischen Lager finden, unterstellt hier. Dass dieser, und das ist jetzt wieder Wortlaut Adenauer, dass diese Entwicklung zwangsläufig ist, zeigt die Geschichte solcher Staaten, in denen Karl Marx, der Messias und seine Lehre das Evangelium ist. Und dann schreibt Wolkenstein hinten dran, dass das, was du eben gesagt hast, die gleiche staatsabsolutistische Logik, so Adenauer weiter, liege auch dem Nationalsozialismus zugrunde. Also diese Hufeisen-Theorie ist da ganz fest verankert. Die CDU hat uns von der staatsabsolutistischen Logik von rechts und links befreit. Und wir dürfen nicht einfach nur Hitler sehen, sondern wir müssen auch die marxistischen Grundlagen in der nationalsozialistischen, in Anführungszeichen, eben Politik sehen. Und davon kamen die nie wieder weg. Also von Anfang an steckt das so drin.
Und würde des Menschen meint aber nicht eine finanzielle Würde, die darin auch besteht, dass man sagt, gut, es muss Wohnraum genug für alle da sein oder so was. Dass man günstige Mieten hat, dass man Erbschaften besteuert oder so was, das liegt alles da nicht drin. Denn Würde meint, dass man nicht in einen totalitarismus verfällt. Und Würde meint aber auch, dass und das ist auch eine Linie, die hier immer wieder aufgezeichnet wird, dass die Demokratie halt so eine Sache ist. Wir können da alle wählen und sind damit gleichberechtigt. Aber eigentlich sollen wir auch schon eine gewisse ständische Ordnung akzeptieren. Wenn du als Krankenpfleger wenig Geld hast, dann solltest du aber nicht jetzt aufbegehren, denn dann denkst du materialistisch, sondern du solltest eher deinen Platz in der Gesellschaft finden und dich auch damit froh begnügen. Und wir sagen dir auch, dass das ganz würdevoll ist, so wie du bist.
Ja, genau. Und das ist die Frage, die ihn beschäftigt und wo er uns diese Superheuristik mit den ganzen Kirchentexten bietet. Denn ausgehend mal von 2015, was ja in Deutschland ein sehr aufregendes Jahr war, also die CDU regiert und man weiß nicht so genau Menschenwürde für Flüchtlinge. Muss das sein? Wer kommt denn auf so eine Idee? Reicht es nicht erstmal Menschenwürde für den deutschen Staatsbürger und so? Und plötzlich steht Merkel dem Papst näher als der CSU-Chef. Und das ist natürlich, ja, wenn man so drüber nachdenkt, das ist schon irre irgendwie. Weil eigentlich ist ja die CSU die wirklich dann katholisch-christlich soziale Union, die eben, naja, dafür, dass CSU-Menschen direkt nach dem Krieg damals uns von Preußen säubern wollten und schon Listen mit 400.000 Namen hatten, von denen sie irgendwie dachten, die sollen mal raus, ist dieses, ja, plötzlich ist es die Merkel, die dem Papst näher steht. Das ist schon bemerkenswert. Also welches Verhältnis hat eigentlich jetzt die Kirche, also der religiöse, organisierte, institutionelle Katholizismus und eben die organisierte Politik?
Es gab ja einmal noch mal so eine ganz starke Verbindung zwischen der CSU und dem Vatikan durch Papst Benedikt, weil Papst Benedikt, also Ratzinger, jemand war, der in den 50er Jahren sich schon stark in diesen Unionskreisen bewegt hat, der ja auch in Bonn war, der dann nach Bayern gegangen ist und der immer diese, nach München gegangen ist und dort immer diese Verbindung gepflegt hat. Und die wurde ja dann auch aufrechterhalten, als er dann Papst wurde. Und dann gab es diese entsprechenden Besuche. Und da hat man es noch mal geschafft, das so zu verbinden. Und auch der Papst sagt ja auch in seinen Memoiren, dass für ihn die CDU in den 50er Jahren ein wichtiges Beulwerk gegen den Kommunismus gewesen sei. Also der hat genau diese Logik, die jetzt hier von Adenauer ausgebreitet wurde, hat er eigentlich total internalisiert gehabt. Und für ihn war das also die logische Konsequenz nur, dass man dann auf Seiten der CDU steht, wenn man Kirchenmann ist. Und das hat sich jetzt aber mit Papst Franziskus gewandelt, weil der natürlich hin und wieder Äußerungen zum Thema Flüchtlinge oder zum Thema Kapitalismus Ungleichheit macht, mit dem die CDU überhaupt nicht mehr klarkommt. Und vor allem die CSU nicht mehr klarkommt. Weshalb es da ja auch dann in den katholischen politischen Kreisen in Deutschland dann solche Leute gibt, die sagen ja, der eigentliche, für uns eigentliche Papst ist Papst Benedikt nach wie vor. Und das ist so ein Irrtum der Geschichte, dass das jetzt Franziskus geworden ist. Also die verstehen jetzt auch ihre Welt nicht mehr so ganz, weil diese alte Seilschaft, die immer bestanden hat, plötzlich zerschlagen wird durch einen Papst, der da überhaupt nicht viel drauf gibt, was irgendwelche deutschen Unionspolitiker meinen und glauben.
Ja, und das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, welche Bögen dann geschlagen werden. Also du hast ja eben schon den Ständestaat kurz umrissen. Man stellt fest, ja, wir haben Menschen. Man klärt erst mal mit sich, haben wir es hier eigentlich mit einer Masse zu tun, die wir von außen steuern oder mit einem Volk, das sich selber organisiert und steuert? Ganz große Frage nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Wie halten wir es eigentlich mit Bevölkerung? Liefern wir sie uns aus oder liefern wir sie umgedreht? Also lassen wir uns von ihnen wählen oder steuern wir sie in die Richtung, in die wir sie brauchen? Und diese große Absage, zum Beispiel in Österreich, der Vorläufer der ÖVP, die Christliche Partei Österreichs, die einfach sagt, ja, Quatschbude, Parlamente sind Quatschbuden, wie Karl Schmidt ja schon schreibt. Wir machen hier einen Ständestaat, den dann auch wirklich organisieren. Und dann wird so nachgetragen als Sinnhaftigkeit. Die christdemokratischen Politikziele sind eben Integration, Klassenkompromiss und nicht Klassenkampf, Akkumulation, Pluralismus. Also ja, wir erkennen irgendwie an, es gibt viele und so weiter. Aber wir halten uns da mal raus. Es gibt hier kein Parlament oder so, sondern wir organisieren sie in Stände. Und die sollen dann einfach in Interessensausgleich aushandeln. Auch in Italien zum Beispiel. Die Kirche, die einfach den normalen Menschen verbietet, an Wahlen teilzunehmen. Weil Demokratie, was soll das schon? Wir wollen hier nicht mitorganisieren. Wir sind nicht die Parteien. Aber wir geben einfach mal an alle Gemeindemitglieder. Und es sind ja nun mal dann alle Menschen gemeint. So die Anweisung, ja, nehmt man nicht an demokratischen Wahlen teil. In Deutschland zum Beispiel. Das ist vielleicht für Politikwissenschaftler so eine These, die man echt noch mal, also würde ich gern noch mal mehr zu lesen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist unglaublich stark in Deutschland. Und wird aber nicht direkt irgendwie gewählt, sondern da werden einfach Richter entsandt. Und wir stellen ja gerade fest, im Vergleich zu dieser lebenslangen Ernennung und so weiter in Amerika hat das ein bisschen Vorteile, wie wir es machen, dass einfach das Parlament so mit zwei Drittelmehrheiten da Richter bestellt. Wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht ein Urteil fällt, hat das Gesetzeskraft wie von der Legislative, ist aber gar nicht direkt demokratisch legitimiert, kann aber gleichzeitig Parteien verbieten, die demokratisch legitimiert werden können, um dann wirklich in Volkes Wille und Repräsentanz Gesetze zu entscheiden. Und diese Machtfülle, gleichzeitig diese riesige Anerkennung und auch diese feierliche Stimmung, die immer herrscht, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht Thema ist, während in Amerika dem ja wirklich gerade eine Legitimationskrise droht, dem zentralen Gericht und in Deutschland eben gar nichts davon. Das ist schon bemerkenswert, dass der Wolkenstein hier sagt, ja, das kommt auch aus dieser Tradition total skeptisch, der Demokratie gegenüber zu sein. Und dann lieber nochmal so ein Bollwerk in Karlsruhe zu platzieren, falls es doch irgendwie schiefgeht.
Wir sehen das ja bei der Geldpolitik, dass das immer dann über Karlsruhe versucht wird, dass man sagt, oh Gott, der demokratische Staat will da was mit Geld machen und will noch Schulden aufnehmen, dann müssen wir mal wieder in Karlsruhe ein Riegel vorschieben. Oder es zumindest versuchen.
Wenn man so einer These weitergeht, ist z.B. die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz ein wirklich antidemokratischer Vorgang. Das haben wir ja auch so thematisiert, aber ohne diese Driftigkeit.
Alexander Thiele ist ja auch jemand, der sagt, er findet das problematisch, wenn alles in die Verfassung reingeschrieben wird. Man fixiert das immer, alles möchte man da drin haben. Er rät davon ab, er sagte, eine Verfassung braucht man natürlich als moderner Staat. Aber dann muss das andere im politischen Raum stattfinden. Und man versucht eigentlich immer, so eine Endpolitisierung zu betreiben. Jetzt haben wir es in die Verfassung geschrieben, jetzt ist das so. Dazu neigen fast alle Parteien, also auch dann bei irgendwelchen progressiven Sachen, dass man sagt, das können wir mal schnell in die Verfassung reinschreiben. Und Alexander Thiele ist da jemand, der sehr skeptisch dem gegenüber ist. Und ich glaube, er hat recht.
Ja, und wir hatten ja auch diesen einen Südekomm-Clip, wo er auch in diesem einen Podiums-Ding nochmal sagt, ja, das ist auch in sich unlogisch, dass wir dem Parlament, von dem wir immer sagen, die Budgethoheit, die Haushaltsdebatten, das ist nun wirklich das Maßgebliche, denen da solche Schranken reinlegen und ihnen eigentlich zu verstehen geben, wir trauen euch nicht, dass ihr mit dem Geld umgehen könnt. Wir machen es lieber so im Grundgesetz. Und vor allem, sie machen es eben selber. So, und eine Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz kann eben nur von der CDU kommen. Die SPD hätte sowas ja nie gemacht. Die macht sowas vielleicht mit, aber...
Nein, die hat aber ordentlich da schon...
Genau, aber...
Das wäre noch eine andere Frage, die ich habe an diesen Text, die der Text aber nicht beantworten muss. Aber das ist eigentlich das Gute, dass der Text eine Grundlage ist für viele Fragen, die man sich dann weiter stellen kann. Inwieweit die SPD sehr stark infiziert ist von der CDU. Also wenn wir jetzt daran denken, wir sehen da Scholz beim Industrietag, der sagt, und da mach ich mal so einen schönen Tisch der Vernunft, da kommen mal alle zusammen und dann machen wir mal einen Kompromiss. Dann ist das sehr nah an dem, was CDU ist. Und die CDU hat ja oft auf den ökonomischen Faden es geschafft, die SPD mitzuholen. Dass die dann mitmarschiert ist da, während es bei den Fragen der Lebensgestaltung, oder des Lifestyles modern gesagt, ja, es die Linken waren, die sich durchgesetzt haben, was ja auch dann für diese Krise sorgt. Aber da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch zu. Ich will noch deutlich waren, das Historische hier. Wir haben jetzt über das 19. Jahrhundert gesprochen. Wir haben da Päpste, die das Wählen nicht toll finden. Bischöfe, die sind nervös. Warum sollen die Leute eigentlich wählen gehen? Aber dann merkt man doch, man kann die Demokratie jetzt auch nicht mehr aufhalten. Also gründet man selbst Parteien, sagt dann, wäre es besser, es gibt christliche Parteien, bevor sonst die Kommunisten siegen oder so etwas. Und dann gibt es in Deutschland ja die Zentrumspartei. Und um das jetzt mal zu verstehen, diese historische Herleitung, warum diese unglaubliche Pluralität da vorherrscht in einer Unionspartei, kann man dann so ein Bismarck-Zitat hier heranführen, der sagt, es gibt nicht zwei Seelen in der Zentrumspartei, sondern sieben Geistesrichtungen, die in allen Farben des politischen Regenbogens schillern, von der äußersten Rechten bis zur radikalen Linken. Das ist wieder dieser katholische Ansatz, den man dann in die Partei hineinträgt. Wir versuchen jetzt alle unter einen Hut zu bekommen, damit es nicht einen Ausstreben gibt, nicht ein Bestreben gibt, dass man versucht, irgendwas radikales zu machen, dass man nicht eine Revolution hat, dass man keinen Umsturz hat. Das geht auch wieder zurück auf das katholische Allumfassende. Das ist auch Karl Schmitt, der wird hier auch ein paar Mal zitiert, als das Genuin Katholische ansieht, dass man diese Widersprüche vollkommen in sich vereinen kann. Weil man alles umfasst, damit aber auch immer auf der richtigen Seite steht. Es ist auch immer alles richtig, weil ja alles beinhaltet ist. Das bedeutet aber auch, jeder, der nicht drin ist, ist natürlich ein Problem bzw. ist der Gegner. Und dann ist die andere historische Tradition, wir haben es jetzt schon angesprochen, die die Papst Leo XIII aufmacht mit seiner Enzyklika rerum novarum. Das ist eine Enzyklika, die 1891 reagiert, darauf, dass es da immer mehr Marxistische Strömungen gibt, die Arbeiter aufbegehren, das vielleicht doch eine Revolution droht. Und da versucht man jetzt Folgendes, da heißt es bei Wolkenstein, rerum verteidigt zwar in antirevolutionärer Absicht das Eigentum als natürliches Recht, betont aber genauso, dass sein Gebrauch ethische Normen und Pflichten unterworfen sein sollte. Gleichzeitig wird dem Staat zugebildigt, rechtmäßig vom Vermögen der Untertanen einen übergroßen Anteil als Steuer einziehen zu dürfen, um die Handhabung des Eigentumsrechts mit dem Allgemeinen wohl in Einklang zu bringen. Diese modernen und geradezu progressiv anmutenden Töne sollten, schreibt Wolkenstein, jedoch nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen, dass rerum von einer natürlichen und naturrechtlich stabilisierten Ordnung der Ungleichheit ausgeht, einer Hierarchie der Über- und Unterordnung der Berufsstände. Diese soll im Sinne des mittelalterlichen Gerechtigkeitsverständnis der Kirche als System von Rechten und Pflichten zwischen Herrschern und Beherrschten eingerichtet werden. Ein System, das der Eintracht und dem Gemeinwohl diene. Und es heißt dann auch tatsächlich in dieser Enzyklika ein Grundfehler in der Behandlung der sozialen Frage ist, dass man das gegenseitige Verhältnis zwischen der besitzenden und der unvermögenden Arbeitenklasse so darstellt, als ob zwischen ihnen von Natur ein unversöhnlicher Gegensatzplatz griffe, der sie zum Kampfer aufrufe. Ganz das Gegenteil ist wahr. Und dann führt er das dann aus, führt Papst Leo das aus. Und das ist exakt der Diskurs, den wir heute haben. Jetzt kommen wir mal alle an den Tisch und jetzt wollen wir doch mal sehen, eigentlich sind wir uns doch eigentlich einig. Und das geht dann bis in diese Schiene der konservativen Journalisten. Denkt man zum Beispiel an den Titel des Buches davon, Jasmin M. Barek, radikale Kompromisse. Da wird also suggeriert, dass es eigentlich keine Interessen, widersprechenden Interessen gibt, sondern am Ende ist es ein Kommunikationsproblem oder man muss sich nochmal neu verständigen. Man muss einen schönen Kompromiss finden, aber eigentlich gibt es diese widersprechenden Interessen nicht. Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert, dass man das einfach mal in so einem Buch nachlesen kann und plötzlich so die letzten 130 Jahre da rückgebunden hat an einen ganz aktuellen Diskurs.
Genau, das, was du gerade zitiert hast, das läuft ja bei Wolkenstein aus dann mit seinem Fazit. Die Antwort des Papstes auf die soziale Frage ist also nicht etwa die Abschaffung der Ungleichheit, sondern ihre harmonische Verwaltung. Das ist ja auch in China. Nirgendwo wachsen mehr Milliardäre aus dem Boden, und gleichzeitig hat man diese große Arbeiterarmut, weil alle kommen in die urbanen Zentren und wissen da erstmal nicht ein oder auch aus. Also harmonische Verwaltung, das Wort Harmonie hier verwendet, finde ich super. Und dann koppelt er das zurück. Die universelle Anerkennung religiöser, also übernatürlicher Wahrheiten, ermöglicht also die Beilegung fundamentaler Konflikte, wie sie auf der anderen Seite als Klassenkampf aufgearbeitet werden. Ich finde 2022 okay, aber für die Zeit, über die wir hier sprechen, also zweite Hälfte 1850 bis 1900 und so, wo wirklich Manchester Kapitalismus, Marx nicht ohne Grund das schreibt, und wir ganz düstere Literatur aus dieser Zeit haben, da plötzlich mit so einer, ja, wir verwalten das mal, wir verwalten jetzt mal die Harmonie, die wir uns hier irgendwie anschreiben. Und falls ihr mit den, falls ihr irgendwo Konflikte seht, ja, dann seid ihr halt mit den übernatürlichen religiösen Wahrheiten noch nicht ganz überein. Dann müsst ihr die mal anerkennen, und dann könnt ihr diese Konflikte auch einfach beilegen. Und sein Fazit ist ja dann, bis ins zwanzigste Jahrhundert hinein war die katholische Kirche selbst weitgehend antimodern und demokratiefeindlich eingestellt. Und das ändert sich dann wirklich erst mit der Erfahrung Holocaust und so. Dass die katholische Kirche da über die Weihnachtsansprachen von dem Eugenio Parcelli, der 1939 zum Papst Pius XII gewählt. Der dann mit seinen Weihnachtsansprachen dann so feststellt, nee Leute, wir können ja echt mal umdenken. Die Menschenwürde und der Mensch überhaupt, nicht nur die Gemeinde und so weiter, können wir hier wirklich mal gewähren lassen.
Nur, glaube ich, muss man nochmal ganz deutlich machen, dass wir dann es noch immer nicht nach 45 mit reinen Demokraten zu tun haben, sondern es bleibt auch weiterhin diese autoritäre Versuchung da. Und es gibt immer wieder Strömungen, die der Demokratie sehr skeptisch gegenüberstehen. Aber natürlich ist die Anpassungsfähigkeit groß genug, sich dann sehr viel klarer dazu zu bekennen. Also dass das ein sinnvoller Weg ist und man auch nichts riskieren will in der Verbindung zu Amerika zum Beispiel. Also wo man natürlich dann Verbündete gefunden hat, die sehr viel Wert darauf legen, dass auch eine Demokratie etabliert wird. Was mir übrigens ein bisschen an dem Buch fehlt, also da hätte ich einfach mir einen Kapitel nochmal zu gewünscht, wäre Familie und Frauen. Und zwar im Sinne von Familie und Frauenpolitik. Das wird ja immer wieder mal kurz thematisiert. Und es wird dann auch gesagt, mit 68 muss die CDU irgendwie mitgehen. Kann natürlich nicht alles mitmachen. Und das ist auch immer so interessant zu sehen. Wir haben ja heute diese Diskurse sehr schnell, wie konservativ die CDU ist. Das ist schon wahnsinnig losgelöst von dem, was die Anfang der sechziger Jahre mal dachten. Aber es wäre dann doch nochmal interessanter nachzulesen, wie eigentlich diese CDU Familien- und Frauenpolitik ausgesehen hat, die nämlich ja auch von so einer naturrechtlichen Grundlage ausgegangen ist. Der Frau steht ein fester Platz im Haushalt zu als Frau, als Mutter. Und wir harmonisieren das, dass also auch der Vater genügend verdient, dass die Frau zu Hause bleiben kann. Und so wird das auch alles harmonisch angeblich austariert. Und jeder bleibt aber dann auch an seinem Platze, der ihm am Ende von der Schöpfung von Gott selbst zugedacht ist. Und diese Verwaltung des Ständischen auf dieser Ebene, das wäre eigentlich auch nochmal ein Kapitel wert gewesen.
Genau. Ich würde sagen, es steht da nicht nichts dazu drin, sondern wie der Heilige Stuhl insbesondere die Zerstörung der Kernfamilie durch Sekularisierung und technologischen Fortschritt verhindern wollte, bis hin zu Ehen sind unauflösbar. Das war ja so eine italienische Doktrin, die es ja noch fast in die Politik so geschafft hätte, ist ein riesen Thema. Insbesondere, und das finde ich eben auch, wenn man auf die Emanzipationsdiskussionen heute schaut und alle funktionalen Argumente da einfach rausstreicht, obwohl sie so wichtig sind, beispielsweise mit Blick aus Erwerbspersonenpotenzial. Wir wollen ja, dass die Frauen sich emanzipieren, weil wir da einfach im volkswirtschaftlichen Interesse mit vertreten. Ohne, dass Frauen intrinsisch eine Karriereidee von sich selber haben und ihre Biografie gestalten wollen, stehen sie dem Arbeitsmarkt nicht zur Verfügung. Sie nützen uns ja am Haushalt nichts mehr. Das ist leider eine ganz bittere Einsicht, die da drinsteckt, aber die, finde ich auch, muss dringend aufgearbeitet werden. Und da bietet er hier zumindest die richtigen Stichworte und Jahreszahlen, wo man da mal nachschauen könnte. Gerade von Italien ausgehend, wo er der Vatikan dann doch noch mal strenger in die Politik reinregierte als in Deutschland, wo es eben die Vereine waren, aus denen dann Parteien entstanden und die Kirche sich da organisatorisch eigentlich zurückgehalten hat. In deren Sicht ist dieser internationale Einschlag, den Wolkenstein ja hat sowieso super, also Salazar, Portugal, ganz ohne demokratische Freiheiten, soziale Gerechtigkeit und gesellschaftliche Harmonie herstellen, steht einfach mal so im Text, geht das. Und das war aber das Ziel. Also Salazar und dann eben auch, und das fand ich auch überraschend, vielleicht hatte ich da einen blinden Fleck oder so. Er nennt nicht nur Oliveira Salazar für Portugal, sondern eben auch Engelbert Dolfus für Österreich und schreibt dann die beiden Diktatoren. Also ich dachte ja, okay, Spanien, Portugal wusste ich, die haben bis in die 70er Jahre in den Diktatoren gehabt, aber Österreich und dann diese beiden Diktatoren, also einschließlich Österreich, begriffen ihre neu geschaffenen Regime als katholische Regime, deren Organisation an die Prinzipien der christlichen Soziallehre angelehnt war. Die haben sich also explizit auf diese Zyklika-Texte bezogen und haben da ihren innerlichen Gehalt rausgezogen. Und da stand eben einfach drin, ach, Wahlen muss das sein, Demokratie, was soll das eigentlich? Den Mensch so, den gibt's ja gar nicht. Wir fühlen uns Gott verpflichtet und leiten da irgendwelche Lehren draus ab. Und dann eben auch das Zitierte von eben, dass man da einfach so eine andere Vorstellung, also wirklich eine grundsätzliche andere Vorstellung hat. Und das aber wirklich bis zum Zweiten Weltkrieg gezogen hat. Erst danach, sagt der Wolkenstein, haben diese Art der autoritären Experimente ihr wirkliches Ende gefunden. Also die CDU konnte da nicht einfach anschließen und sagen...
Hier haben sie ihr Ende gefunden, muss man dazu sagen. Denn Orban ist jemand, der offenbar ein bisschen diese Traditionen kennt, auch wenn er eigentlich gar nicht aus einer solchen kommt. Also die Partei hat sich ja fast auch so ein bisschen Start-up-mäßig eigentlich gegründet, könnte man fast sagen. Also es ist nicht so diese lange Linie. Genau, als liberale Kraft. Und dann hat er aber diesen Turn gemacht hin zum Konservatismus und dann zum Nationalismus. Und wo er auch dann deutlich sagt, nein, Christdemokratie, das meint eigentlich illiberal zu sein. Also es geht also die Christdemokratie kämpft in Orbans Vision gegen den Liberalismus. Und das meint aber zugleich der Wirtschaftsliberalismus bleibt. Plus zu einem korrupten System, dass man dann selbst um sich nochmal aufbaut. Aber der Liberalismus im Sinne von Rechte für Frauen, für LGBT oder auch überhaupt eine moderne Lebensweise, das ist etwas, wogegen gekämpft werden muss, weil das dann so etwas wieder wie eine marxistische Unterwanderung der Kernfamilie ist.
Ja, und wenn man sich hier nochmal die Dramatik anschaut, also dieser Turn, dann einfach zweiter Weltkrieg. Pacelli wird also 1939 zum Papst gewählt, das heißt Pius XI ist noch vor Ausbruch des zweiten Weltkriegs gestorben. Dennoch wird er hier von Wolkenstein nochmal als eigentlich jemand, oder ich lese mal vor, wie es hier steht, in den letzten Lebensjahren des erzkonservativen und ursprünglich profaschistischen Papst Pius XI setzte im Vatikan nämlich ein vorsichtiges Umdenken ein, weg vom Faschismus und hin zur Affirmation universeller Menschenrechte. Wenn man das so liest und zeitlich einordnet, versteht man so ein bisschen, die brauchten einfach wirklich den Zivilisationsbruch in der echten Welt und die totale Zerstörung Europas, um hier von ihren Lehren mal abzurücken irgendwie. Und dann beginnt eben der nächste Papst mit diesen Weihnachtsansprachen und stellt dann irgendwie fest, ja, Masse und Volk predigt dann irgendwie dazu. Er findet plötzlich das Individuum, redet so über die Würde des Einzelnen oder den Wert des Einzelnen und so weiter und so fort. Aber die Kirche als so maßgeblicher Ideentreiber und Ideengeschichtenschreiber für diesen christdemokratischen politischen Versuch, den wir bis heute irgendwie jetzt belächeln wollen, aber unter dem er halt einfach handfest eingreift in das Schicksal der Welt, die brauchten einfach einen richtigen Holocaust, um da mal Lehren draus zu ziehen. Und es ist schon erschreckend, wenn man diese Starrheit, diese innerliche Tringenz dann mal so dargeboten bekommt von so einem Politikwissenschaftler, der sich diese Sachlage einfach mal anschaut.
Ja, das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, dass man in den 30er-Jahren dort die Demokratie als etwas so Furchtbares ansieht, auch weil man sich so sehr gegen eine materialistische Denkweise stellt, dass man einfach Realitäten ignoriert. Also du hast es ja eben auch gesagt, mit dem 19. Jahrhundert, mit der arbeitenden Klasse, wie es ihr ergangen ist, dass man das einfach komplett ausbindet und sagt, wir harmonisieren da mal irgendwas, wo die wirklich verehlenden im buchstäblichen Sinne. Und dass man dann hier eigentlich eine Gesellschaft sich heranzüchtet, die nur dann zu befrieden ist mit einer Ideologie, die sich nicht damit auseinandersetzen will, dass der Kapitalismus in seiner modernen industrialisierten Erscheinung natürlich das Zusammenleben grundlegend verändert. Also wenn Marx und Engels schreiben, alles Stehende und Ständische verdampft durch den Kapitalismus, dann ist das etwas, was die Katholiken hätten auch begreifen können und andere Schlüsse daraus ziehen. Aber sie blenden eigentlich dieses Ökonomische, solange es irgendwie geht, aus und basteln sich dann solch merkwürdigen Konstrukte, bis es irgendwann gar nicht mehr geht. Also das ist ja dann auch genauso mit 68 oder so passiert, dass die CDU an allem festhält und so muss eine Mutter sein, so ist eine deutsche Hausfrau, bis sich dann alles so aufgelöst hat und der Arbeitsmarkt alles zusammenbrechen würde, bis man sagt, ach so, ja gut. Sie sollen auch schon arbeiten gehen und Kinderbetreuung ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Ja, und jetzt sitzen wir hier so hier und haben uns ja auch schon die Frage gestellt, wo ist denn die Kirche, was sagt sie denn zu Corona? Und sie sagt ja gar nichts.
Ja, wir hatten ja Franziscus, den hatte ich ja damals vorgespielt, der dann nur so sagte wie, wir waren zu schnell, wir waren zu rastlos unterwegs in dieser Welt. Ja, was soll das schon sein?
Ja, und in Deutschland eben, die Kirchen, die durften ja immer offen sein, für die gab es ja keinen Lockdown. Es war ja grundgesetzlich vorgesehen, Kirchen sind offen. So, da kann man hingehen. Diese vor Ort, klar mit Maske und Abstand und so weiter, aber anders als Schulen, Vereine und alles, waren Kirchen immer offen. Also die haben einfach keinen Bezug zur Realität, weil sie in so einer eigenen Realität leben. Bis heute, ja. Wie lange hat es gedauert, den sexuellen Missbrauch mal einem weltlichen Gericht zu unterstellen? Wir leiten ja im Grunde unter diesem Missbrauch, der stattfand und dann auch unter der Art und Weise, wie die Kirche das selber aufgearbeitet hat. Oder eben nicht. Also es zieht sich ja bis heute. Und ich finde, falls du nicht noch einen Aspekt hast, würde ich das Finale des Buches, diese fünf Zeilen, einfach zitieren. Denn die sind wirklich stark. Ja, mach das mal. Wolkenstein kommt ja mittendrin auf Papst Leo, den 13. Und der mit seiner Enzyklika Novarum, also den unbestritten wichtigsten Text oder das unbestritten wichtigste Dokument der Frühphase der katholischen Soziallehrer. Und Schlussfolger dann hier. Die katholische politische Theorie für die Moderne, die entworfen wurde von Papst Leo, dem 13., deren Inhalt ausschließlich aufs vormodernen Quellen abgeleitet wurde, zurückgehend bis Thomas von Aquin. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja gut, er war aber auch ziemlich moderne Thomas von Aquin, aber ihm war ja eigentlich gerade auch nur dran gelegen, rückblickend, was haben eigentlich die Griechen und so weiter gemacht. Also immer nur Blicke zurück.
Ja, und bei Thomas ist ja dieser naturrechtliche Gedanke ganz, ganz entscheidend. Und da kann man das alles wieder gut rückwinden. Ich will nur noch eins einwerfen, bevor wir das vergessen. Als Papst Benedikt im Bundestag gesprochen hat, war sein Thema Naturrecht. Und er hat das aber verknüpft mit Schöpfung und Naturschutz. Und was er natürlich auch damit sagen wollte, war, na ja, jeder hat schon seinen Platz. Zum Beispiel auch, was Familie anbelangt, was sexuelle Neigung anbelangen muss, was man zu sein hat und was man nicht sein sollte. Also es ist ganz interessant, wie stark das vertreten ist. Und natürlich ist Benedikt großer Thomasechse geht.
So, und dann kommt Wolkenstein zum Schluss. Pie, Pa, Po. Und wir lesen das Ende. Zum anderen sollte man sich ein für alle mal von der Prämisse verabschieden. Die christdemokratische Politik der Gegenwart und Zukunft müsse unbedingt von der Vergangenheit inspiriert sein. Das heißt freilich nicht, dass die Geschichte der Christdemokratie keine Bedeutung für ihre Gegenwart hätte. Aber vielleicht sollte es die Christdemokratie tatsächlich wagen, an der Spitze des Fortschritts zu marschieren, das ist Zitat Strauß, statt nach Ideen aus früheren Jahrhunderten zu kramen, dass die Schluss-Poande damit dem überzeugen, konservativen Franz Josef Strauß gehört, darf als gewollte Ironie aufgefasst werden. Das finde ich sehr gut. Manchmal schreibt man ja Bücher, um auf ein Problem aufmerksam zu machen. Und dann stellt man mittendrin fest, es gibt ja gar keine Lösung. Wir können ja wirklich einfach nur das Problem mal verstehen, aber wie lösen wir jetzt demografischer Wandel oder das mit dem Klima usw.? Ja, was sind denn die Lösungen? Einfach immer nur mehr Aufmerksamkeit draufzulegen, macht ja den Leuten nur schlechte Laune. Wir wissen ja von Linien, eine Revolution findet statt, wenn die Leute eine bessere Alternative für, die sie kämpfen können haben und nicht usw. dagegen. Und jetzt diese ganze Rückwärtsgewandtheit der Christdemokratie. Und dass er dann einfach sagt, Sie könnten ja eigentlich mal nach vorne schauen, dann kommt er mit diesem Franz Josef Strauß Spruch und macht im Grunde nur die Pointe, Sie sagen es, aber Sie machen es nicht. Die Semantik ist da, aber die Struktur eben nicht. Und dazwischen liegt so eine große Lücke, dass wir die einfach nur noch mal als Problem markieren können. Und Schluss. Denn was haben wir gerade von der CDU? Und das ist jetzt eben, wir müssen den Humor jetzt einfach aufnehmen. Die CDU versucht gerade Zukunft zu gestalten mit Friedrich Merz, den alle nur gewählt haben, weil er vor 20 Jahren, als alles noch in Ordnung war, das Gesicht im Fernsehen war, und man dachte, dann fühlt sich so an, wie wenn Thomas Gottschalk noch mal das macht. Dann fühle ich mich wie vor 20 Jahren, als alles noch in Ordnung war. Das ist der Mut.
Den Namen habe ich auch jetzt gerade sofort gedacht. Sofort, als du Merz sagtest und sagtest von vor 20 Jahren, das ist der Programmdirektor, der sagt, wir müssen mal irgendwie so einen Samstagabend machen. Gottschalk, das wär's.
Ganz genau. Und in der Hinsicht, wir sind leider alle nicht mehr biblfest, weil wir zu modern sind. Die Bibel ist für uns eine Literatur, die man auch einfach ignorieren kann. Wenn wir biblfest wären, könnten wir der CDU sie gerade um die Ohren hauen. Und sie damit in ihrem namentlichen Kern, in ihrem Markenkern, von dem wir jetzt gehört haben, sie hat darüber hinaus kein Programm, könnten sie jetzt da ärgern. Leider sind wir alle nicht biblfest. Und sind zu dieser Pointe, die dann da möglich wäre, zu den vielen Pointen nicht in der Lage, aber so ein Norbert Röttgen im Fernsehen zu sehen, wie er einfach jetzt über Russland, und das ist aber wirklich der Böse und der Putin und Waffenstillstand, dürfen wir niemals machen, weil dann würden ja nur Putin so eine Ruhephase ausnutzen, um uns dann wieder und so. Ja, solche Verdrehungen. Eigentlich müsste man da so richtig reinspringen können.
Genau, da müsste man sofort mit der Bergpredigt reinspringen und da müsste man mal überlegen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und das sollten wir nochmal hier ganz deutlich machen. Ich bin ja, wie man weiß, ausgetreten aus Gründen aus der Evangelischen Kirche, aber ich habe mich hier nicht abgewandt vom Christentum und würde das hier nochmal ganz deutlich machen wollen. Christdemokratie meint natürlich nicht, dass die Politik mit der Bibel machen, sondern das ist sehr, sehr losgelöst davon, sondern man bezieht sich auf die Institutionen, vor allem auf die katholische Kirche. Man kann die evangelische Kirche im Übrigen ganz gut auch ins Boot holen. Es gibt ja auch einige große CDU-Unionsleute, die evangelisch sind, zum Beispiel eine ehemalige Bundeskanzlerin. Das schafft man aber auch dadurch, dass man sich eint im Antikommunismus. Also man sagt, eigentlich sind die evangelischen ein bisschen näher an diesem Staatsabsolutismus dran. Und dieses Antipreußische ist ja dann auch sehr ins Antievangelische, Antiprotestantische gegangen, dass es in den 50er-Jahren, Anfang der 60er-Jahre noch getrennte Schulen gab für Protestanten und Katholiken. Das ist ja absurd, wenn man daran denkt, das ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her. Aber das gab es bei meinen Eltern. War das noch nicht so ganz selbstverständlich, also dass jetzt die evangelische Frau den katholischen Mann heiratet. Also das ist einfach dann noch Realität gewesen vor gar nicht so langer Zeit. Da hat man aber durch diesen Antikommunismus die evangelischen mit ins Boot genommen. Und was ich aber hier deutlich machen will, ist, dass es nicht christlich also was die machen. Also wenn man jetzt tatsächlich zurückgeht zur Bibel, zur Botschaft Jesu, dann wird man feststellen. Nee, dann ist natürlich die Menschenwürde etwas, was allen zukommt. Da müssen wir auch gar nicht mehr darüber diskutieren, ob da auch Flüchtlinge mit dabei sind oder nicht. Und das würde einen anderen Blick auf Kriege natürlich einem ermöglichen und würde einem auch einen anderen Blick im Zusammenleben ermöglichen. Und es gibt ja auch andere politische Strömungen des Christentums, die in Deutschland aber nie so richtig Fuß gefasst haben, also nur so in den intellektuellen Kreisen dann rezipiert wurden. Zum Beispiel die Befreiungstheologie, die in lateinamerikanischen Ländern sehr stark war, gegen die sich ja auch ein Franziskus, bevor er Papst war, immer wieder gewandt hat. Aber da steckt quasi ein progressiver Kern im Christentum. Und denen würde es zu beleben gelten. Aber das sollte man nicht von der CDU erwarten, also die macht das keinesfalls, sondern man müsste da jetzt sie mit den eigenen Waffen schlagen und sich eigentlich das drauf schaffen, um dann in der Talkshow einem Norbert Röttgen oder wem auch immer entgegnen zu können und zu sagen, das ist jetzt eigentlich hier eine christliche Politik. Und diese christliche Politik ist dann auch alle umfassend, also die meint dann nicht, und jetzt müssen erstmal alle Christen werden, alle christianisiert werden, damit man mitmachen kann. Aber das ist quasi das Potenzial, das im Christentum selbst liegt, das aber natürlich von einer bürgerlichen Partei nicht erkannt werden will. Und hier geht es am Ende dann doch auch ganz stark darum, Macht sich abzusichern und die entsprechenden institutionellen Stellen so zu besetzen. Ich fand das wirklich eine sehr, sehr weitsichtige und hellsichtige Lektüre, auch deshalb, weil man so viele Länder darin vorkommen sieht, was sonst eigentlich so im Diskurs nicht so ist und auch wie Kohl ein großes Interesse daran hatte, so eine europäische Gemeinschaft der christlichen Parteien zu etablieren. Und man sieht aber dann auch die Schwierigkeiten heute, müssten nicht die konservativen Union und so weiter sich nicht viel stärker von urban absetzen. Und warum sie das dann doch nicht können, also was sie sich eigentlich dafür ein Konstrukt gebaut haben, das ist schon toll nachzulesen, also was da auch so in den 70er, 80er, 90er Jahren auf europäischer Ebene passiert und welche Seilschaften da entstehen. Und wo man dann sagt, naja, der Berlusconi, das ist eigentlich das Gegenteil von dem, was wir wollen, aber so ganz ohne geht es vielleicht auch nicht.
Ja, und passend dazu, weil wir uns ja drüber lustig machen wollen, ist jetzt Boris Johnson tatsächlich zurückgetreten. Zumindest hat er gesagt.
Tatsächlich, jetzt wo wir da sprechen.
Er macht seinen Weg frei, passt ja irgendwie zum Tage, wo wir dieses Buch besprechen. Auch wenn jetzt England nochmal. Kommt ganz am Rande vor.
Und da gibt es aber eine interessante Idee, dass eine gewisse also Labor in England ist ja sehr außergewöhnlich, was danach 45 passiert. Das ist ja so ein bisschen paradiesisch, würde ich fast sagen. Und die beziehen sich aber auch auf christliche Werte. Das wird ja da so an einer Stelle. Also das müsste man nochmal nochmal genau nachlesen. Aber das finde ich also nochmal an anderen Stellen. Es heißt also, das lasst mich das noch gerade, weil ich das so überraschend fand. Wenn Gleiches aus heutiger Sicht schwer vorstellbar ist, gilt es gesondert hervorzuheben. Durch ihre sowohl antikommunistische als auch antiliberale Ausrichtung waren die meisten der neu gegründeten Christdemokratischen Parteien wirtschaftspolitisch Mitte-Links-Parteien. Einige wollten überraschenderweise direkt an britische Tradition des demokratischen Sozialismus anknüpfen. Die ÖVP definierte sich unmittelbar nach dem Krieg etwa als sozial engagierte Sammelpartei, die ideologisch in wesentlichen Punkten der britischen Labour Party nahestehe. Also man hat da so eine ganz merkwürdige Verbindung. Und dann heißt, warum diente ausgerechnet die britische Labour Party vielen wirtschaftlich links stehenden Christdemokraten als Vorbild, nicht aber die kontinentaleuropäischen Arbeiterparteien. Vieles spricht für die Erklärung, dass das politische Selbstverständnis der Labour Party seit ihrer Gründung stark von der Ideologie des christlichen Sozialismus geprägt wurde. Und das zeigt aber auch, das hätte auch in eine andere Richtung gehen können in den 50er Jahren. Also die Christdemokratie hätte sich da anders orientieren können. Aber dann hat man da natürlich mit Deutschland AG und so weiter ein Umfeld sich geschaffen, wo man dann sich von Labour sehr weit entfernt hat. Aber das hier noch mal so nachzulesen, wie eigentlich da diese Labour Party so eine Verbindung zum christlichen Sozialismus hat, ist, glaube ich, sehr lohnenswert. Das leistet das Buch nicht, soll es auch nicht. Aber das ist, glaube ich, ein Thema, das man nochmal verfolgen könnte.
Ja, sehr guter, abschließender Gedanke zum Buch.
Was ist los bei den Konservativen? Was ist los bei der CDU? Um diese Frage beantworten zu können, muss man sich erst einmal fragen, was war dann in der Vergangenheit dort eigentlich so wichtig? Was waren die großen Linienverbindungen? Und das ist etwas, was Fabio Wolkenstein mit seinem Buch Die dunkle Seite der Christdemokratie wunderbar aufzeigt. Das ist ein verrückter Haufen, diese Konservativen. Und ich glaube, sie werden uns noch lange erhalten bleiben.
Das glaube ich auch. Und Lektüre erlebnismäßig kann man sagen, nach David Graepper und Michael Sendel, die wir hier gelesen haben, bekommen wir noch mal so ein geschichtsheuristisches Werk, das uns auf unglaubliche Weise die Augen öffnet für ganz moderne aktuelle Probleme und uns eben genau die Materialien liefert, um das besser zu verstehen, die wir selber so gar nicht nachlesen können. Also in der Hinsicht eine sehr schöne Materialarbeit, die wir euch allen empfehlen.
Stefan, wie viele Apps hast du auf deinem Handy, um dir Essen liefern zu lassen oder dich über Essen zu informieren oder Restaurants zu buchen, was auch immer?
Also ich habe. Ich kriege häufig Mails von Uber, weil ich mir die Uber App mal installiert habe, aber nie gebraucht habe, noch nie benutzt, dass mir über Essen liefert. Finde ich ganz merkwürdig, habe ich nicht verstanden. Ich habe nicht als App, aber als Shortcut Chefkoch die Rezepte Sammlung, in der ja alle so ein bisschen kollaboriert zusammentragen. Ich habe einen Kalorienzähler, von dem ich weiß, dass es sehr gut funktioniert. Ich scanne also irgendwas ab, um mich mal kurz zu... Also ich mache für keinen Kalorien-Tagebuch, aber ich weiß, ich kann bei jedem Nahrungsmittel, das ich finde, mal kurz abscannen, wie es ist zusammengesetzt und so weiter. Darüber hinaus bin ich essensmäßig auf meinem Handy eigentlich gar nicht so... Ich habe jetzt nichts weiter, was mir irgendwie in den Sinn käme, was mit Ernährung direkt zu tun hat.
Ja, du bist dann nicht so ganz repräsentativ vielleicht. Tatsächlich hast du jetzt schon Uber erwähnt und es gibt ja das Tochterunternehmen Uber Eats und das ist sehr beliebt. Und zwar ist das, wenn man die Quartale 22, 21 vergleicht, das erste Quartal und das vierte Quartal von... Das erste Quartal von 22, das vierte Quartal von 21. Wenn man diese Quartale vergleicht, dann gibt es da Top Ten-Listen. Die wurden von diesem State of Mobile Report von Data AI erstellt. Dann ist erstaunlich, auf Platz fünf ist Uber Eats, der am meisten downloadeten Apps. Auf Platz eins Edeka Genuss, dann Too Good To Go. Das ist eine App, die versucht, Essen zu sammeln, das man dann günstig kaufen kann, das nicht gebraucht wurde oder wiederverwertet ist, also dass das so ein bisschen so Recyclinggedanken hat. Platz drei, die Pem App. Weißt du, was das ist?
Nee.
Das ist die App von Pamela Reif, dieser Influencerin. Das ist ja so Deutschlands bekannteste Fitness-Influencerin, die im Übrigen aber auch 37 Millionen Follower in China hat. Und die hat eine eigene App entwickelt. Sie hat in einem Podcast mal gesagt, ich glaube, diese Entwicklung der App hat fast eine Million gekostet. Und man denkt sich, was, eine Influencerin gibt eine Million aus, um eine App zu entwickeln. Offenbar mit Erfolg auf Platz drei. Und dann sind einige Sachen, die ich nicht so kenne, aber natürlich auch Rewe ist darunter HelloFresh flink. Und das ist das Entscheidende vielleicht erst mal an diesem Report. Es gibt natürlich einen großen Boom. Und jetzt hatten wir diese Lockdown-Phase. Und klar, dann haben viele Leute sich irgendwas kommen lassen. Tatsächlich geht der Trend aber trotzdem weiter. Also im ersten Quartal 22, verglichen mit dem ersten Quartal 21, gibt es überall Anstiege. Die sind mitunter aber nicht mehr so schnell. Also die normalen Lieferdienste sind um 5 Prozent nur gestiegen. Aber die ultrafast Delivery Services wie zum Beispiel Flink, die einem dann versprechen, in 10 oder 15 Minuten ist alles da, die auch ja jetzt zum Teil erst vor kurzer Zeit entstanden sind, die haben einen Zuwachs, so 1. Quartal 21 bis 1. Quartal 22, verglichen miteinander von plus 266 Prozent. Also klar, die entstehen jetzt auch neu, dann werden die erstmal downgeloadet. Also dieser Report wertet ja auf, was laden die Leute herunter oder welche App benutzen sie am häufigsten. Und dann gibt es diesen unglaublichen Zuwachs. Aber auch, was stark gestiegen ist, nämlich um 40 Prozent, ist, dass man sich Lebensmittel liefern lässt. Dass man also nicht mehr zum Edeka geht oder zum Rewe geht, sondern dass man es sich liefern lässt. Klar, auch sonst so Review-Seiten für Restaurants oder Reservation-Apps, all das ist gestiegen. Aber gerade diese beiden Zahlen sind interessant. 40 Prozent bei den Lebensmittel-Zulieferern und bei diesen Ultrafast-Delivery-Services 266 Prozent. Das ist natürlich ein urbanes Phänomen, aber ich glaube, dass dieses Ultrafast sich auch noch weiter ausbreiten wird, auch so in mittelgroßen und kleineren Städten. Sicherlich nicht auf dem Land, da ist das dann nicht möglich. Nun, was sagt uns diese Auswertung, die hier vorgenommen wurde noch? Generell gibt es also bei allen Food- und Trink-Apps, die man sich so vorstellen kann, einen Anstieg. Der ist nicht mehr ganz so stark wie dieser Lockdown-Druck, aber wenn man sich das dann nochmal so länderspezifisch anseht, dann sieht man auch welche enormen Wachstumsraten, welche auch Schwankungen es da gibt zwischen den Ländern. Also die stark industrialisierten Länder, wie jetzt Großbritannien, Frankreich, Deutschland, da tut sich dann mitunter nicht so viel. Aber wenn man sich ansieht in Indien, da gibt es zum Beispiel Zahlen darüber, wie stark das Wachstum ist bei den Food- und Drink-Apps, also wie stark die jetzt gedownloadet werden. Dann kommt man da auf Zahlen, dass es jetzt ein Plus von 80 Prozent zum Vorjahr gibt. Und Ähnliches ist in Indonesien zu beobachten. Offenbar hat man da jetzt sich einen Markt erschlossen. Da gibt es einen Anstieg von 380 Prozent.
Also ich finde es interessant, dass da so viel Bewegung ist, weil ich mich immer gefragt habe, wo bleibt sie denn? Das ist in Deutschland vor allem dieses superschnelle, das verstehe ich gar nicht. Denn mittlerweile geht man doch auch bei Amazon-Sachen und so dazu über, sich so ganz allmählich einen Wartekorb zusammenzusammeln. Man hat doch jetzt das Vertrauen, das wird dann geliefert, wenn man es braucht. Man muss es aber nicht jetzt sofort bestellen. Und dann sammelt sich das so an und dann irgendwann macht man die Bestellung dann einfach. Und dass man beim Essen es so eilig hat, nicht einfach zu sagen, er schickt es heute Abend vorbei, sondern ich will es in zehn Minuten. Das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht. Also was für ein stressiges Leben haben denn die Leute, damit man wo das gerechtfertigt ist irgendwie?
Nein, ich glaube, es ist wirklich die Überlegung, ich habe jetzt Hunger und hätte das jetzt gerne und dann kommt das in zehn Minuten.
Erwart man nicht Zeug zu Hause, falls man selber kocht?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Also ich glaube, der Kühlschrank ist relativ leer bzw. wahrscheinlich könnten viele schon ohne Kühlschrank fast auskommen. Also müssten nur noch so eine Kühlbox haben, dass man so lange noch das Getränk kalt stellen kann. Aber wenn man sich ansieht, dass täglich in Deutschland 100.000 Food und Drink-App-Downloads stattfinden, noch immer, also wir sind ja schon auf einem hohen Niveau wahrscheinlich. Jeder hat ganz, ganz viel schon da auf dem Handy. Und trotzdem gibt es da im Schnitt 100.000 Downloads. Auch das ist hierbei herausgekommen. Das, finde ich, ist eine enorme Zahl.
Ja, das sind alles ganz komische Entwicklungen. Auf der einen Seite so dieses händeringende Kommt, macht eine Kasse, wo die Leute noch mal quatschen können, weil sie kommen jeden Tag einkaufen. Sie haben ja sonst nichts zu tun. Auf der anderen Seite dieses superschnelle Ich lass es mir noch mal in meinem urbanen Lifestyle nicht nehmen, mir das einfach schicken zu lassen, weil selbst die fünf Minuten runter zum Supermarkt irgendwie sind mir zu lang. Ja, da sieht man auch, wo so die Unterschiede sind mittlerweile.
Und du hast ja jetzt eben gesagt, du hast da mal irgendwas runtergeladen und hast es dann doch nie benutzt. Das ist aber bei diesen ultra fast delivery apps tatsächlich nicht so. Ich habe ja gesagt, es gibt diesen Anstieg von 200 auf um 266 Prozent. Und wenn man sich aber dann ansieht, wie sehr wird diese App genutzt, dann gibt es da auch einen Anstieg um 213 Prozent. Das heißt also, die App wird nicht nur mal runtergeladen und hat es einmal probiert, hat sich einmal was kommen lassen und danach geht man wieder einkaufen. Nein, man bleibt offenbar dabei. So jetzt dein Thema Demografie hoch interessant. Was wird eigentlich von wem besonders frequentiert? Und da ist es so, dass die Boomer sehr viel Lebensmittel sich liefern lassen.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, weil die Boomer ja doch so eine nicht eine besondere Technik Affinität haben. Also eine hohe Service Affinität, aber nicht so viel so Technik getrieben.
Ja, also die Gen X plus Baby Boomer, also alles, was über 45 ist, wird hier allerdings aufgelistet. Also Boomer sind ja dann eigentlich noch mal sehr viel älter. Von daher stimmt das sicherlich, dass das dann abnehmen wird eher. Aber da kann man das beobachten, dass über 30 Prozent der Nutzung von solchen Lieferdiensten für Lebensmittel frequentiert werden von über 45-Jährigen. Und dann kommen die Millennials mit 40 Prozent und der Rest sind dann Gen X. Und in Großbritannien dasselbe Bild. Also 30 Prozent bis 40 Prozent der Briten der Generation 45 plus frequentiert diese Apps, die Lebensmittel bringen. Der größte Balken ist immer der der Millennials in allen Ländern, in Australien, Brasilien, Frankreich. Aber man sieht da offenbar bei den Boomer ein großes Interesse daran, dass man sich Sachen liefern kann.
Also ich habe mir noch nie so weder fertig zubereitetes, noch zubereitendes Essen, also HelloFresh oder so. Die Nachbarn hier machen das so. Ich keine Ahnung, das ist noch nicht so mein Lebensstil. Ja, aber interessant, dass es da so eine große Bewegung gibt.
Und da sieht man dann auch, wenn man sich anschaut, was haben die Baby Boomer auf ihrem Handy und was hat Gen X auf ihrem Handy, also die 45 plus Leute, das ist einmal Chefkoch. Das scheint mir so eine Rezeptio-Sache zu sein, die hast du auch. Und dann kommt aber schon Edeka und Penny an dritter Stelle. Also da wird offenbar Wert drauf gelegt, dass man das bekommt. Bei den Millennials auf Platz eins Rewe, dann Too Good To Go, diese App, die da nochmal so wiederverwertet war, dann natürlich KFC, Flink ist aber natürlich auch dabei, Gorillaz und bei der Gen Z, also bei den ganz jungen, was ist die erfolgreichste App, Food und Drink App?
McDonalds?
Natürlich. Richtig, McDonalds. Dann Platz zwei Lieferando, Platz drei Burger King, Platz vier Uber Eats und Platz fünf Subway. Und dann kommt die Pam App. Da macht man ein bisschen gesunde Ernährung und Sport, damit man danach wieder die App numero uno anklicken kann, die McDonalds App.
Genau. Ich war jetzt kürzlich auch mal bei McDonalds und fand es ganz interessant, weil du kommst ja rein, kannst natürlich immer noch boomermäßig an den Schalter gehen und einfach sagen, was du willst.
So mache ich es ja.
Wenn du gehst du so häufig zu McDonalds?
Ziemlich häufig, wenn ich unterwegs bin zu Vorträgen, dann ist es ja oft so, dass man nur noch so eine Stunde Zeit hat, muss noch mal schnell ins Hotel und dann gehe ich an den Warnhöfen zu McDonalds und esse Pommes und schicke McNuggets und gehe dann aber hin und bestelle das. Aber du weißt ja, ich fahre ja noch Zug. Drucke mir das Bahnticket aus und dann ganz wichtig, also das ist wirklich so Boomer, ganz wichtig, ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen unsexy, es zu erzählen, aber ich mache es trotzdem.
Lass mich raten. Dann musst du mit so einer Büroklammer, klammerst du deine Bahnenkarte an ein Ticket.
Nein, was mache ich? Ich schiebe den Ausdruck in eine Klarsichtfolie.
Jetzt kennen wir dich alle in- und auswendig, Wolfgang. Also meine Erlebnis bei McDonalds, ich fand es interessant, ich habe das jetzt das erste Mal so erlebt, gibt es aber schon eine Weile, weiß ich, dieses große Bestellding an diesen Bildschirm. Und man steht ja echt so ein bisschen da und denkt sich, man, das hätte ich auch auf den Weg anklicken können, dann käme ich hier rein und das wäre schon fertig. Und ich glaube, das verleitet viele, sich die App runterzuladen. Ich habe, also ich bin kein McDonalds Wiederholungstäter, aber diese Idee von ich laufe durch die Stadt, überlege mir, ich gehe zu McDonalds und dann bestelle ich das schon mal mit allen Leuten auf der App und komme dann an und es ist fertig. Die finde ich wirklich gut. Also das ist super Fast Food und wenn das so gut funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle, dann ist das, glaube ich, nicht schlecht. In deren Sicht hat McDonalds da noch mal was rausgeholt, glaube ich. Also mein Gefühl. Aber wie gesagt...
Scheint mir auch so zu sein. Man kann es dann noch anders machen. Ja, jedenfalls ist dieser Report abrufbar. Man muss aber sagen, man muss sich da anmelden, um da dran zu kommen. Man muss da eine E-Mail-Adresse und eine richtige Adresse und Telefonnummer hinterlegen und eigentlich wollen die das nur an Firmen rausgeben. Man kommt aber, glaube ich, auch so dran. Also die haben sich jetzt auch nicht dafür interessiert, dass ich nur Podcaster bin. Also wer das nochmal dann auf der Teil nachlesen will und auch so den Ländervergleich sehen will, kann das machen. Aber eigentlich waren das, was ich jetzt hier aufgezeigt habe, so die entsprechenden Zahlen, was wir uns merken. Die Boomer lassen sich jetzt inzwischen auch viel Lebensmittel liefern und ultrafast wird immer wichtiger. Unglaublicher Anstieg, was nicht heißt, dass diese ultrafast Liefer-Services besonders profitabel sind. Nämlich wenn man sieht, wie da gerade die Börsenkurse nach unten gehen und wenn man sieht, dass die auch bei ihren neuen Runden, wo sie Geld eintreiben wollen, plötzlich keine Investoren mehr finden, dann kann natürlich sein, dass dieses System noch mal ordentlich durchgerüttet wird. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es verschwinden wird. Wahrscheinlich wird das irgendwann dann sich so entwickeln, dass es einfach etwas teurer wird und damit wird es dann profitabel, vielleicht irgendwann. Aber dass das verschwinden wird, glaube ich nicht. Dafür haben sich schon jetzt zu viele Leute an diesen Service gewöhnt.
Ja, im Buch habe ich geschrieben, Deutschland hat wenig eigene technologischen Fortschritte, um sich für den demografischen Wandel vorzubereiten oder um sich auf ihn einzustimmen, ist ja da, außer im ganz hochpreisigen Fahrassistenzsysteme, die es schaffen. Also da muss man aber echt eine S-Klasse super aufgemöbelt kaufen, um das. Ich verstehe das gar nicht, warum Mercedes diesen Vorsprung, den sie da haben in der Technik, nicht einfach nutzen, um das so in die Breite irgendwie zu bringen. So wie Tesla das ja macht. Klar, es sind auch teure Autos, aber eben man muss nicht erst sechsstellig bezahlen. Und eine Ausbeuter-Liefersache für Essen mit Lieferando und dem ganzen Kram und Gorillas. Das ist ja alles gruselig zu sehen, wenn man sich mal diese auf der Arbeiterseite das anschaut, wie das da organisiert wird. Bleiben wir beim Einkaufen. Gehen wir mal weg vom Lebensmittel. Auch gekauft werden muss ja Energie, wie wir gerade feststellen. Und da gab es einen Gastbeitrag von Mohamed Ado zum Thema Was macht Scholz in Afrika? Er selbst kommt von der Power Shift Afrika. Das ist irgendein Think Tank, der in Nairobi sitzt. Und mit Power Shift ist das gemeint, was wir so unter Energiewende verstehen. Und wir haben ja, als wir thematisiert haben, dass Olaf Scholz in Afrika ist, das sehr gelobt. Denn Merkel hat ja zehn Jahre gebraucht, um irgendwann und eine Flüchtlingswelle, um dann irgendwann mal nach Afrika zu fahren und zu feststellen, hm, hier sind ganz schön viele Menschen und es werden noch mal ganz schön viel mehr. Und vielleicht ist ja dieses Jahrhundert das Afrikanische. Immerhin schrumpft die Welt insgesamt, was die Bevölkerung angeht. Aber in Afrika werden es eben noch mal ein paar Milliarden Menschen mehr. Es stellt sich heraus, nein, man muss große Kritik an diesen Besuch von nicht nur Scholz, sondern auch Draghi usw. äußern. Denn, Zitat, jahrelang haben wir Afrikaner die reichen Länder dazu gedrängt, sich von fossilen Brennstoffen unabhängig zu machen und die Treibhausgasemission drastisch zu verringern. Schließlich erleben wir in Afrika die Klimakrise an vorderster Front. Vor allem Dürre usw. In den vergangenen Monaten hat sich Italiens Ministerpräsident Mario Draghi so intensiv wie noch nie um neue Gasabkommen mit Algerien, Zypern, Angola, der Republik Kongo und Mosambik bemüht. Bei jedem Abschluss –die Klauseln bleiben weitgehend unter Verschluss –war der Vorstandsvorsitzende der italienischen Öl- und Gasgesellschaft Eni dabei. Eni ist der größte Mineralölkonzern, der auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent aktiv ist. Es sind also nicht irgendwelche Chinesen oder so, es ist Europa, das gerade wieder Afrika ausbeutet. Bei seinem Besuch im Senegal gab Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz bekannt, dass die Regierung beider Länder bereits –Zitat –intensive Gespräche über eine Zusammenarbeit bei Erdgasförderung und Flüssiggasproduktion führen. Es geht also um den Aufbau einer dafür notwendigen Infrastruktur und künftiger Kraftwerke, also für Transport und Herstellung. Und das ist natürlich besonders blöd für Afrika, weil man die jetzt so lockt mit Investitionsunterstützung. Wenn ihr bei euch so ein fossiles Industrieding aufbaut, dann habt ihr uns als Kunden. Heißt aber, ihr müsst, um in diese Zukunft zu gehen, jetzt Gaskraftwerke bauen und sowas. Und das sind natürlich Investitionsanreize, wo man sich so ein bisschen denkt, ne, warte mal, hat nicht Ursula von der Leyen gesagt, also in Afrika ist Wind und Sonne kein Problem. Wieso fördern wir da jetzt Gas? Wieso zwingen wir den Sonne? Wir versprechen euch ein bisschen Profit, baut mal bitte eine Gasinfrastruktur auf und so. Also eine Erdgasinfrastruktur.
Und du weißt ja, worauf das dann hinausläuft. Dann wird man, wenn wir uns dann irgendwann mal tatsächlich unabhängig gemacht haben von dem Gas, 2040, dann wird man wahrscheinlich den Afrikanern sagen, ja, also mit eurer Industrie, ihr macht da ja immer noch so viel Schmutz, das geht ja nun gar nicht.
Genau. Und das ist nämlich auch der Kritikpunkt. Er hat Angst davor, dass diese Länder dann einfach fallen gelassen werden, wenn die Brückentechnologie, na gut, dann holen wir das Gas nicht von da, sondern von da, wissen, aber es ist wahnsinnig teuer, was hier nur zu mehr Windrädern führt und irgendwann reichen die Windräder und dann braucht man das Gas dann nicht mehr. Also das Interesse der Öl- und Gaskonzerne des globalen Nordens in Afrika steht und fällt mit der politischen Attraktivität fossiler Brennstoffe und den Plänen der Länder, ihre Emissionen zu verringern. Und wir haben ja großes Interesse, das zu verringern. Also sieht man schon, worauf es hinausläuft. Und Afrika sollte diese Bemühung als das erkennen, was sie sind, ein zynischer Versuch, Profite aus einer umweltschädigenden und scheiternen Industrie herauszuschlagen, die verlorenen Investitionen während des unvermeidlichen Übergangs auf Afrika abzuwälzen. Also ein sehr guter Einspruch, der hier gelegt wurde. Er kommt in Musambik auf den Zyklon Idai zu sprechen. Alles klimawandelbedingte, wirklich tiefe Eingriffe da ins Land. An der Küste investiert ENI, also der italienische Konzern da, für 20 Milliarden, bauen die da Offshore-Erdgas-Förderanlagen und so. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und 70 Prozent des Landes, Musambik, sind selbst von Stromversorgung abgeschnitten. Also wir fahren dahin, bauen da Gasinfrastruktur für uns auf, während 70 Prozent des Landes, den wir den Gas abkaufen, einfach energetisch auf dem Trockenen sitzt, also wirklich nicht angeschlossen ist an das Versorgungsnetzwerk. Unglaubliche Zustände schon wieder. Und Europa, es ist nicht Afrika, sondern das ist wirklich Europa hier, wo wir ja gerade diesen Wertekampf haben.
Ja, das ist das Absurde. Wir sagen, wir müssen, um unsere Werte zu verteidigen, schnell aus dem russischen Gas und dem russischen Öl raus. Wir wollen uns jetzt die weiße Weste anziehen. Und das machen wir natürlich nicht. Sondern wir bleiben schmutzig nur auf eine andere Weise.
Ja, und es läuft hier in der Formulierung auf das Finale hinauf. Jetzt wollen uns Deutschland und Italien, ungeachtet der Leiden, die sie damit verursachen, eine Infrastruktur wie fossile Brennstoffe aufdrücken. Es ist an der Zeit, dass wir Afrikaner nein sagen und stattdessen den Übergang zu einer sauberen Energieversorgung beschleunigen, die unserem Kontinent wahren Wohlstand und echte Sicherheit bringen wird. Die Argumentation, die jetzt ganz dringend zu machen ist, ist, wenn Afrika, und damit meine ich jetzt den ganzen Kontinent, egal wo, ganz Afrika ist reich an solchen fossilen Bodenschätzen. Wenn Afrika sein Wirtschaftswachstum die nächsten 100 Jahre darauf fundiert, diese Sachen auszubeuten, also CO2 aus dem Boden zu holen und in die Luft zu blasen, dann ist einfach hinüber. Es ist eigentlich der europäische Auftrag, die Technologie zu entwickeln, die uns erneuerbare Energien zur Verfügung stellt und diese Technologien den afrikanischen Ländern zu schenken. Und wir werden damit vergütet, dass die das Klima nicht vollendst zerstören.
Dass die alles im Boden lassen, was sie rausholen und gut verkaufen könnten.
Genau, weil wenn man das Wirtschaftswachstum, das erwartbar einsetzt, während die Bevölkerung von 1,5 auf 4,5 Milliarden bis zum Jahrhundertende wächst, wenn man das mit fossilen Brennstoffen gestaltet, dann ist einfach finito. Also dann sind hier acht Grad mehr auf der Erde. Das kann niemand wollen. Das ist einfach eine ganz falsche Rangehensweise. Das ist wirklich sehr enttäuschend, das von Scholz überhaupt so zu lesen, dass diese Reise so stattfand. Und naja, im Grunde geht es darum, wenn wir uns in Deutschland wirklich konzentrieren könnten, 20 Prozent Gas zu sparen für den jetzt anstehenden Winter, kämen wir mit den Kalkulationen, die Habeck gemacht hat, durch. Und nur weil man nicht genau weiß, soll man es mit verboten machen, reichen Habecks Appelle, traut sich jemand einen Appell zu, das lachen ja schon wieder alle über den Tweet von Olaf Scholz, hinsichtlich die Ölkonzerne, und bitte, bitte und so, und alle schreiben drüber, ja, wenn ich Kanzler wäre, würde ich da mal durchgreifen. Ach so, du bist ja Kanzler.
Ja, was ist ja so, also ich meine, warum, man kann ja, das sind ja diese Energiekonzerne, an die da appelliert wird, sind ja dieselben, die jetzt da gerade in Afrika ihr Unwesen treiben. Dass man denen nicht mit Appellen kommen kann, ist ja nun vollkommen logisch. Also das kann man vielleicht noch irgendeiner Oma aufschwätzen, Gelddreh mal die Heizung ein bisschen runter, damit wir den Russen nicht das ganze Gas abkaufen müssen. Aber sonst kann man mit Appellen wirklich niemanden erreichen. Und ich weigere mich auch regelrecht, Appelle mir anhören zu müssen von Politikern.
Ja, ich will noch mal dran erinnern, wir haben häufiger Christian Lindner als den gefährlichsten Mann Europas bezeichnet. Christian Lindner haben wir vor einer Woche noch gehört, wie er dem BDI sagt, ihr dürft eure Übergewinne gern behalten. Ihr seid ja auch sehr innovativ, liebe Ölbranche. Ja, und gleichzeitig sowas in Afrika da. Das passt also alles nicht zusammen. Diese Antipolitik der FDP muss da ganz dringend bekämpft werden. Und es ist unsere europäische Aufgabe, jetzt erneuerbare Energien technologisch so zu gestalten, dass man die überall auf der Welt aufbauen kann, insbesondere dort, wo die Sonne so krass scheint. Also es ist wirklich unglaublich, was wir hier von der Entwicklung gerade sehen.
Wir blicken nach Russland und versuchen jetzt noch mal, eine andere Argumentation aufzugreifen. Etwas, was auch nicht mit Norbert Röttgen in den Talkshows debattiert wird. Und zwar Branko Milanovic hat ja auch einen Blog, den ich sehr empfehlen kann. Da schreibt er über politisches und über wirtschaftliches. Und da ist ein Text erschienen im Juni mit dem Titel What if Putin's true goals are different? Also was, wenn Putin's wahre Ziele andere sind? Da beginnt er erst mal damit, dass er sagt, nach jedem Standardindikator, der das erreichte, daran misst, inwieweit die erklärten Ziele verwirklicht wurden, war Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine ein Misserfolg. Ja, wir haben ganz klar von Putin gehört, was er da eigentlich vorhat. Und dann sagt Milanovic aber, vielleicht aber auch nicht. Denn nehmen wir an, dass die wirklichen Ziele, der in Anführungszeichen militärischen Sonderoperationen, nicht die angekündigten waren, sondern ganz andere. Und nun überlegt er, was könnten diese Ziele sein? Was wollen eigentlich Länder, fragt sich dann Franco Milanovic. Und er sagt, die streben nach zwei Gütern. Und was wollen auch Führer von Ländern? Die wollen Souveränität und Wohlstand, sagt er. Und führt dann aus. Souveränität bedeutet, die Freiheit, politische und wirtschaftliche Entscheidungen zu treffen, die so wenig wie möglich durch andere Länder eingeschränkt werden. Wohlstand bedeutet ein hohes Einkommensniveau, also in Klammern hohes Pro-Kopf-BIP. Das Problem ist, dass es einen Kompromiss zwischen diesen beiden Zielen gibt. Länder können nur dann reich werden, wenn sie weniger souverän, das heißt stärker global integriert sind. Um reich zu werden, müssen sie handeltreibend Technologien gemeinsam mit anderen entwickeln, Menschen ins Ausland schicken, um neue Fähigkeiten zu erlernen, sich mit Ausländern beraten, sogar Ausländer einstellen. All dies setzt eine viel stärkere Interdependenz zwischen den Volkswirtschaften und die Einhaltung internationaler Normen und Regeln in Bezug auf Handel, geistige Eigentumsrechte, indische Wirtschaftspolitik, Konvertierbarkeit von Währungen und dergleichen voraus. Und jetzt nimmt er mal zwei Beispiele, um das besonders extrem zu verdeutlichen, Nordkorea und Belgien. Nordkorea, sagt er, ist wirtschaftlich und politisch frei. Es kann Atomwaffen herstellen, weil es sich an gar keine Verträge hält, Zölle erheben, wie es will, Einfuhr von Waren verbieten. Es kann so viel oder so wenig Geld drucken, wie es will. Die Währung muss gar nicht mehr eingetauscht werden, kann ja auch nicht. Aber aus all diesen Gründen, schreibt Milanovic, ist es auch sehr arm, dieses Nordkorea. Am anderen Ende des Spektrums steht Belgien. Das keine eigene Währung hat, dessen Finanzpolitik durch die Regeln der EU eingeengt ist und dessen Handel von der EU und der WTO bestimmt wird. Die Außenpolitik wird von der EU bestimmt und das militärische Engagement von der NATO. Was die innenpolitische Autonomie oder Souveränität angeht, so hat Belgien praktisch keine. Aber Belgien ist sehr reich. So und dann sagt er die USA ein bisschen Sonderfall natürlich großes Land. Und trotzdem sagt er die USA werden bei einem gegebenen Einkommensniveau mehr Souveränität genießen, weil sie ein großes Land sind. Sie geben eine Reservewährung heraus. Sie sind der Hauptakteur einer Reihe von Handelsverhandlungen. Außerdem gibt es die NATO. Aber es wird nicht immun sein gegen diesen Kompromiss. Denken Sie an Trumps Entscheidung, den Handelskrieg mit China zu beginnen. Das hat den USA mehr politischen Spielraum verschafft, aber wahrscheinlich auch ihre Einnahmen geschmälert, sagt Milanovic. Und nun kommt er zurück zu Russland, dieser russische Isolationismus. Worauf könnte denn dann hinauslaufen? Und da meint er, er geht da auch nochmal in die Historie zurück, mit dieser Vorstellung eines Kompromisses zwischen diesen beiden wünschenswerten Dingen wollen wir nun zu Putin und seiner Gruppe von Beratern aus Machtministerien zurückkehren. Nehmen wir an, sie kämen zu folgendem Schluss. Die Versuche Russlands, sich seit Peter dem Großen zu verwestlichen, sind gescheitert. Das könnten die ja denken. Vor 1917 hat Russland den Anschluss an den Westen nicht geschafft. Dann hat es eine extreme Verwestlichungsdoktrin angenommen, die Russland durch die völlige Unabhängigkeit Finnlands, Polens und so weiter verkleinert hat. Dann die Gleichheit der Nationen und das Selbstbestimmungsrecht für alle proklamiert, was schließlich 92 zum Zusammenbruch des Landes führte. Danach übernahm es den ebenfalls aus dem Westen importierten Liberalismus, dessen Folgen eine dramatische Verarmung der Bevölkerung, eine Zunahme der Sterblichkeit und der Selbstmorde, sowie der erstaunliche Raub von Vermögenswerten waren, die von Millionen russischer Bürger geschaffen wurden. In dieser Zeit verlor Russland seine Fähigkeit, allein über seine Politik zu entscheiden. Es folgte dem Westen lindlings. Es bot den USA seine Militärstützpunkte in Kirgisistan an, erhielt aber keine Gegenleistung. Es stimmte einer begrenzten Erweiterung der NATO zu, wurde aber selbst mit einer Erweiterung bis an die Grenzen verwöhnt. Es trat verschiedene europäischen Gremien bei, wurde aber von diesen kritisiert. Dann privatisierte man die Wirtschaft, westliche Experten schlugen einiges vor, aber das Geld ging ins Ausland. So könnten die auch sich die Geschichte erzählen. Und dann sagte er, es muss eine unabhängige eurasische Macht werden. Das könnte man sich denken, deren Interaktion mit Europa auf ein Minimum beschränkt sein wird. Letztendlich muss Russland die entgegengesetzte Richtung einschlagen könnten, also diese Berater und Putin denken, die Peter, der große Anfang des 18. Jahrhunderts, eingeschlagen hatte. So, und wenn man jetzt sagt, vielleicht denken die so, dann bedeutet das aber auch etwas für die Sanktionen und auch überhaupt damit, inwieweit wir Russland schaden oder in welchem Verhältnis wir da eigentlich zueinander stehen. Denn er sagt, dass von der russischen Führung in diesem Szenario angestrebtes Ziel, Russland vom Westen abzuschneiden, wird nicht von der russischen Führung, sondern vom Westen erreicht werden. Also der Westen könnte möglicherweise, wenn die Russen die Geschichte so interpretieren und so ihre künftige Politik betrachten, dann könnte der Westen gerade nicht die Russen ärgern, sondern eher das machen, was Russland will. Die russische Führung wird von der Bevölkerung nicht als verantwortlich für die Zerstörung des Traums von Peter dem Großen angesehen werden. Im Gegenteil, der Westen wird als nicht gewillt angesehen werden, Russland als gleichberechtigten Partner zu akzeptieren. Und Russland wird von daher keine andere Wahl haben, als eine eurasische Macht zu werden, die völlig souverän ist. Nicht durch Verträge und Regeln eingeschränkt, frei von westlichen Ideologien des Marxismus und Liberalismus. Und die Menschen würden nicht akzeptieren, dass man ihnen sagt, ja, wir haben da so eine politische Vision, ihr werdet jetzt bald alle ein bisschen ärmer. Das würde nicht funktionieren. Wie ließe sich das aber vermeiden, dass man so eine solche Ansprache überhaupt halten muss, oder dass man dann das auf sich bezieht? Wie kann man, fragt Milanovic, den Bruch dauerhaft machen? Da sagte er, die einzige Möglichkeit besteht darin, die Kosten für eine Rückkehr in den Westen außerordentlich hoch anzusetzen. Das heißt, man muss dafür sorgen, dass bei den ersten Versöhnungsangeboten der nach Putin-Regierungen die Rechnung des Westens so hoch ausfällt, dass die russische politische Elite und die öffentliche Meinung sie von vornherein ablehnen muss. Und da muss man noch mal so an Norbert Röttgen denken, mit seinen ganzen Forderungen. Maximal-Forderungen. Das könnte eigentlich ganz im Sinne der Russen sein, dass sie sagen, ja, guck mal, das können wir nun wirklich nicht anrufen. Also das geht dann nicht. Das versteht ihr doch auch, ihr Bürger. Und dann sagen die, ja, dann leben wir lieber mit weniger, als dass wir uns in der Weise blank ziehen müssen vom Westen.
Find ich alles klug argumentiert, steckt bestimmt einiges drin. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja schon erste Wortregung, wir hatten die Idee, glaube ich, hier auch mal, dass man die eingezogenen und eingefrorenen Vermögen als russisch deklariert lässt, also auch zurückgeben kann. Aber die Bedingungen, unter welchen, klärt man dann mit dem Nachfolger Putins, sodass man gleich sozusagen eine Mitgift hat für die Wiedereingliederung Russlands, zum Beispiel in so eine G7-Plus-Strukturgespräche oder was auch immer. So eine NATO-Annäherung, vielleicht hat er doch mal eine eurasische Idee oder so. Da muss ich natürlich auch Europa emanzipieren, aber das mal außen vor. Ich bin nicht ganz überzeugt, ich finde es ein bisschen plausibel, aber es wäre auch... Es scheint mir so eine Theorie zu sein, die aus der Frage erwächst, jetzt, da Putin mit dem, was wir eben unterstellt haben, nämlich er übernimmt die Ukraine einmal von einer Woche und erklärt sie dann einfach zu russischem Staatsgebiet, so wie mit der Krim, dass das ist gescheitert. Welcher andere Sinn könnte denn noch zu finden sein? Also, dass man so nachträglich einen Sinn sucht, wo vielleicht dann doch keiner so steckt, sondern alle nur versuchen, sich so vorwärts zu arbeiten.
Naja, wenn man sich aber vielleicht mal losmacht von dieser Überlegung, die wir anfangs hatten, dass wir sagten, gut, was will der eigentlich mit der Ukraine? Dieses bitterarme, aber sehr große Land. Und diese Frage ist ja unbeantwortet eigentlich. Und wenn man dann aber sagt, vielleicht ist Wohlstand nicht die Kategorie, sondern hier ist das andere, was für Führer und Staaten wichtig sein kann, nämlich die Souveränität, worum es geht, dann kann man natürlich sich fragen, ob man nicht einfach ist, mit einem Putin zu tun hat, der einen Machtblock konturieren will und vielleicht dann gerade durch diese heftige Reaktion, die das ausgelöst hat, genau dieses Ziel erreicht. Also ich glaube auch, das wird jetzt nicht die Antwort auf alle unsere Fragen sein. Ich glaube nur, dass ein solches kontraintuitives Denken uns am Ende sehr viel weiterführt in der Beschäftigung mit dem Krieg, als in diesem üblichen Modus so drin zu sein. Und auch nochmal zu sagen, ja, es wird ja irgendwann eine Nach-Putin-Regierung geben. Er wird nicht ewig leben. Das ist sicher so. Aber auch da zu sehen, was bedeutet das denn eigentlich und was wird da jetzt gelegt? Und wie hoch sind die Kosten für diese Rückkehr? Denn momentan liegt ja nichts weiter fern, als dass wir nochmal mit den Russen enger kooperieren werden. Und er sagt dann auch, dass diese nach Putin Regierung diese Sanktionen, also die Kosten dafür, wieder sich anzugleichen, also was dann alles Russland machen müssten, wenn die zu hoch sind, dass das überhaupt nicht mehr als sinnvoll erscheint, dann hat man damit dauerhaft so eine Abkopplung geschafft. Und er sagt dann, diese Sichtweise der russischen Ziele hat zufolge, dass die Sanktionen und die Entkopplung zwischen dem Westen und Russland nicht mehr nur als Kosten betrachtet werden, die Russland zu tragen hat, sondern dass der Westen das tut, was nach Ansicht der gegenwärtigen Führung im grundlegenden langfristigen Interesse Russlands liegt. Alle Verbindungen zwischen Russland und dem Westen abzubrechen und damit Russland die Freiheit zu geben, seinen eigenen Weg zu gehen. Ich halte das nicht für so, ich meine, das hat es immer wieder gegeben, solche Alleingänge.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall gut, mal diesen Fokus so drauf zu legen, weil das ja bedeutet, wenn Putin so ein Ziel wirklich verfolgt, bedeutet das ja, er muss grundsätzlich eine Situation herstellen, in der selbst wohlwollendste Angebote des Westens jetzt mit Russland wieder zu kooperieren oder das wieder aufzubauen, das Verhältnis, dass die von russischer Seite versagt bleiben. Und das kann ja nur gelingen, wenn die Propaganda so funktioniert, dass man wirklich über Jahrzehnte jetzt so Missgunst und Hass da schürt. Und in der Hinsicht finde ich es super relevant, so einen Text zu besprechen, weil man dann den Fokus darauf legen kann, dass wir uns zu wenig ein Bild davon machen, wie die in Russland gerade denken und zum Denken gebracht werden. Also was da im Fernsehen wirklich gesendet wird, was da so Stimmungsmache ist. Denn das scheint ja dann wirklich tiefgreifend relevant zu sein für die Frage, welches Schicksal droht uns denn nach Putin? Dass dann wirklich einer gewählt wird, weil er so wie Putin ist und das Erbe weiterführt? Oder besteht nicht doch irgendwie die Chance, dass da anders gewählt werden kann?
Es wäre eigentlich dann gut, man müsste jemanden haben, der diese ganzen Fernsehsendungen übersetzt, dass man die sich immer so zu Gemüte führen kann, dass man das immer so dann ein paar Stunden bekommt aus der Woche, was so vorgefallen ist, dass man mal so wirklich einen Querschnitt eigentlich hat. Bei dir natürlich immer nur so einzelne Auftritte von Putin sehen und immer dann, wenn es besonders irr wird, dann wird da eine Meldung draus. Aber mich würde einfach so das alltägliche Verhandeln von Krieg, von russischer Nationalität und so interessieren, um ein bisschen Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was denkt da eigentlich eine Mehrheitsbevölkerung darüber? Und zwar nicht nur über den Krieg jetzt, sondern generell über den Westen. Weil sich das ja auch herausgestellt hat bei vielen Korrespondenten, die in China waren, dass sie dann erlebt haben, dass plötzlich auch so die jungen Leute auf so einem antiwestlichen Trip sind. Und sich nicht mehr für amerikanische Fast-Food-Ketten oder so interessierten, weil ihnen das zu amerikanisch war. Und man hat so einen Stimmungsumschwung, den man erst gar nicht so genau verstehen kann, den man aber spürt. Und wenn das natürlich sich da rechtzeitig etabliert, dann kann das natürlich für die Regierung nach Putin auch bedeuten, dass man diesen Kurs in irgendeiner Weise weiterfragen muss.
Und da würde ich jetzt gerne direkt, wirklich direkt anschließen, denn da stellt sich ja die Frage, welche, also wenn einiges Russland einfach einen Nachfolger für Putin aufbaut und dann ist er da, klar, dann ist das geritzt. Aber angenommen gewinnt eine Opposition. Welche denn dann? Und da gab es in Le Monde Diplomatique, lesen wir alle sehr gern, von Ilja Butreidskis, eine Aufschlüsselung Russlands Kommunisten und der Krieg. Und mit Russlands Kommunisten sind also die Oppositionsparteien gemeint, die man da so wohlwollend duldet. Unterzeile Applaus für Putin, Sowjet-Nostalgie und leise Kritik. Also, am 21. Februar, heißt es im Text, legte Putin seine Ideologie da. Er hat ja dann eine Stunde lang erklärt, was er sich da vorstellt. Und dann drei Tage später hat er angegriffen. Und da drin fiel unter anderem der Satz, die heutige Ukraine wurde voll und ganz und ohne jede Einschränkung von Russland geschaffen. Genauer vom bolschewistischen, kommunistischen Russland. Man kann sie heute mit Fug und Recht als Vladimir Lenin Ukraine bezeichnen. So, und direkt im nächsten Absatz. Und das ist für uns natürlich besonders interessant, weil wir diese 2005er Merkel und so weiter Szenerie kennen. 2005 hat Putin noch den Zerfall der UED SSR als größte geopolitische Katastrophe des 20. Jahrhunderts bezeichnet. Und Merkel hat es ja gespiegelt mit. Für mich war es der tollste Moment des 20. Nicht nur meine biografische Erlösung. Ich konnte sogar Kanzlerin werden, sondern eben auch für die Länder, die es betraf. Eine tolle Sache. Und heute sieht Putin die eigentliche Tragödie gar nicht im Ende der UED SSR, sondern in ihrer Gründung. Zum Zerfall unseres geeinten Landes führten historisch strategische Fehler der Führung der KPDSU. Sagt er nun und warf Linien vor, in der sowjetischen Verfassung das Recht jeder Republik festgeschrieben zu haben, die Union zu verlassen. Also wir haben bei Putin ja ein sozusagen retrospektives Sense-Making. Er schaut zurück, um da Sinn für sein gegenwärtiges Handeln rauszuziehen. Aber es ist nicht der Wunsch zurück zur Sowjetunion, sondern er möchte die Fehler in der Gründung eigentlich noch mal korrigieren oder direkt anschließend an die Zeit davor. Und das ist hier ganz interessant, denn mit dem Ende der Sowjetunion kam ja diese Idee der Demokratie irgendwie kurz auf. Also dieses Jelzin-Zeitalter wurde irgendwie so wohlwollend aber auch belächelnd im Westen aufgenommen. Und in Russland selber wurde die KPRF, also die Kommunistische Partei der Russischen Föderation, zugelassen. Eigentlich wollte man die Kommunisten aus dem Land jagen und nichts mehr mit denen zu tun haben, aber irgendwie hat man sich dann doch darauf verständigt. Kommt, wir lassen jetzt eine Neugründung dieser Partei zu. Die hat auch seit 1993 denselben Chef. Das ist ganz interessant. Also da ist eine hohe Konstanz, aber eben nicht inhaltlich. Gennady Siuganov heißt der Chef. Vielleicht hat denn jemand den Namen gehört. Ich finde es immer interessant, wenn da jemand 30 Jahre lang die Oppositionspartei in Russland anführt. Ich habe den Namen noch nie untergekommen. Diese Partei hatte teilweise 500.000 Mitglieder. Sie hat auch von denen Geld kassiert, natürlich Mitgliedsbeiträge, und sich darüber finanziert. Irgendwann hat aber der Staat gesagt, wir helfen euch mal ein bisschen, dafür aber, dass ihr wohlwollende Opposition macht. Sie speist heute noch zu 6% aus den Mitgliedern und zu 89% aus staatlicher Förderung. Man sieht, in welche Richtung es ging. Aber es ist bei den Wahlen immer so die erfolgreichste Partei. Und zwar auch, unabhängig davon, ob man in urbanen Zentren oder auf dem Land ist. Auch diese Nawalny-Idee, wir stellen so Gegenkandidaten auf als Sammelbecken, kam so über Wahlerfolge von Einzelnen hier, weil er da schon so ein Sammelbecken gesehen hat, aber eben abhängig vom Staat. Also er wollte dann sozusagen diese Idee aufgreifen. So Kommunismus, wir haben ja eben schon bei der CDU gehört, das sind halt die Antikommunisten, das ist so ihr Markenkern. Und hier ist es halt nochmal die Erinnerung an den Kommunismus usw. Die stellen sich also auf. Und es gibt sie so. Und jetzt gehen die Jahre ins Land. Wir nähern uns diesem ukrainischen Krieg. Am 19. Januar, während russische Truppen an der Grenze aufmarschierten und die westlichen Staatschef den Dialog mit Putin fortsetzten, reichten 11 kommunistische Abgeordnete in der Duma eine Resolution ein, in der sie den russischen Präsidenten dazu aufforderten, die Unabhängigkeit der Volksrepubliken in der Ostukraine anzuerkennen und dem Genozid dort der dortigen Bevölkerung ein Ende zu setzen. Also die Ideologie, die zum Krieg führte, zumindest den Teil öffentlich, den wir mitbekommen haben, nämlich das sind eigentlich russische Gebiete und da findet ein Genozid statt, kam aus dieser Oppositionspartei in die Duma, ins Parlament und wurde dort als Beschlussvorlage im Januar schon dargelegt. Da gab es diesen Truppenaufmach-Show und man hat sich schon gefragt, wann passiert hier was, müssen die jetzt in den Böden gefrieren und so weiter. Ich kann mich noch so dunkel erinnern, wie wir das diskutiert haben. Naja, es war eine Absage an das Minsker Abkommen, ganz wichtig. Also mit diesem Beschluss oder mit dieser Vorlage für den Beschluss, mit diesem Antrag in der Duma durch die Opposition, dass man jetzt die Gebiete anerkennt und so weiter, hat man dem Minsker Abkommen sozusagen den Garaus gemacht, dass Donetsk und Luhansk als Teil der Ukraine anerkannt hatten. Also das war ja das Minsker Abkommen. Und kam eine direkten Kriegserklärung gleich. Also eigentlich hat die Duma den Krieg erklärt, wie ein Parlament eben die Kriege erklärt, formal gesehen. Es ist ja auch in Amerika immer noch das Parlament, das im Vorrecht hat, wenn jetzt nicht Patriot Act und so gewesen wäre. Anfänglich war diese Initiative der Parlamentsmehrheit von einiges Russland zu radikal. Also die Putin-Partei, die da saß, hat gesagt, das ist uns zu scharf. Aber einen Monat später wurde das Papier mit absoluter Mehrheit der Duma verabschiedet und bildete die Grundlage für den Überfall. Also die formale und inhaltlich ausformulierte Grundlage kam aus dieser kommunistischen Opposition über den Duma-Beschluss in den Kreml und wurde dann einfach vollzogen. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich trotzdem vorstellen, dass das auch lanciert wurde und so. Aber das ist schon mal ein ganz interessanter Weg, weil jetzt eben diese Opposition…
Ja, auch einen großen Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung hat diese kommunistische Partei.
Genau. Also nicht so wie Putin, aber… Es ist immer so 11, 15 Prozent und so in den Wahlen.
Es ist doch ganz erstaunlich. Also auch da diese Hoffnung auf große Oppositionen in Russland…
Genau.
ist dann schwierig.
Genau. Die wurde also irgendwie vereinnahmt oder war sogar Antreiber. Was für uns bedeutet, ja, wenn Putin weg ist und eine neue Partei gewählt wird, heißt das denn gleich, dass das dann irgendwelche westlich gesinnten Demokraten sind? Nein, natürlich nicht. Es gibt da Hardliner überall. Allerdings –und das ist jetzt der Kniff hier in der Geschichte –allerdings gehören auch die drei einzigen russischen Abgeordneten, die den Mut hatten, öffentlich gegen die Invasion in der Ukraine zu protestieren, zu dieser kommunistischen Fraktion. Sie ist also wirklich gespalten worden. Mehrere KPRF-Abgeordnete aus der Region Primoriye, der Oblast Vorenish und so weiter. Also der Text ist sehr detailliert. Und der Republik Jakutien haben sich gegen den Krieg ausgesprochen. Also es gab verlautbare Opposition. Wir haben ja gehört, wie die Leute von der Straße weggeholt wurden, wenn sie nur so taten, als würden sie ein Schild hochheben. Es gab hier Politiker, die tatsächlich explizit ihren Widerspruch geäußert haben, öffentlich. Und damit eben auch nicht nur in Konflikt mit der Regierung, sondern auch in Konflikt mit ihrer eigenen Partei kamen. Und die Pointe dieses Textes ist nun, dass die Oppositionspartei, diese relativ starke kommunistische Partei dort gespalten ist. Und weil ja Putin, wie der Text darstellt, so einen Sinneswandel hatte, 2005 noch zu sagen, das Ende der Sowjetunion ist die größte Tragödie der Geschichte. Und nein, jetzt ist es die Gründung. Man hat es nämlich falsch gegründet. Man hat den Ländern Freiraum gegeben. Die Ukraine hätte nie überhaupt die Idee entwickeln dürfen, aus so was auszutreten. So, und jetzt ist die Pointe in diesem Text. Doch kamen nicht 1917 mitten im Ersten Weltkrieg diejenigen, die die russischen Soldaten zur Befehlverweigung aufriefen, wie jetzt diese Opposition der Opposition in dieser kommunistischen Partei, gegen jede Erwartung an die Macht. Sie waren es auch, die schließlich die Ukraine in ihren heute anerkannten Grenzen schufen. Noch ein Grund für Putin, Lenin zu hassen. Also es ist total verdreht, dass wir hier so eine Wiederholung nach 100 Jahren Geschichte haben, wo Oppositionskräfte irgendwie hineinwirken, während eines Krieges zu Befehlverweigerungen aufrufen und dann nach Abschluss dieses Krieges, aber auch die Macht übernehmen, neu gestalten und dann so gestalten, dass man jetzt 100 Jahre später wieder darauf zurückkommt und sagt, das war damals falsch und gleichzeitig wieder so eine Opposition provoziert, bei der wir nicht wissen, ob sie vielleicht nach Putin dann doch so einen Gesinnungswandel herstellt mit Leute, hört mal zu, Putin ist jetzt weg. Wir können jetzt alle mal wieder, je nachdem, wie das gestaltet werden kann, ehrlich miteinander sein und sagen, Krieg ist scheiße, vor allem auch gegen ein Brudervolk wie die Ukraine. Das ergibt ja auch innerlich keinen Sinn, dass wir 100 Jahre behaupten, das sind eigentlich wir und dann führen wir plötzlich Krieg. Also diese Dissonanzen muss man ja erstmal auffangen und vielleicht schaffen die das ja. Also es steckt so eine kleine Hoffnung hier in dem Text, dass demnächst wieder Kräfte die Macht erringen, die bisher einfach unterdrückt wurden, aber eigentlich viel größer sind und stärker sind, als man so vermutet, weil das auch die einzigen sind, die sich gerade in den letzten drei Monaten öffentlich gegen Putin äußerten und den Krieg verurteilt haben. Also in deren Sicht, je nachdem. Es ist immer wahnsinnig schwer. Man liest immer nur so einzelne Facetten aus solchen riesigen, nicht nur regionalen Gebilden, sondern auch politisch Problemlagen und Zuständen. Und dann versucht man da irgendwie so Sinn rauszufinden. Aber ich fand diesen kleinen Einwurf hier, Blick auf die Opposition in Russland, nicht uninteressant.
Suche nach Sinn, Frage nach dem Warum. Das ist auch etwas, was Johannes Siegmund beschäftigt. Wir Zukunftslosen heißt der Essay, erschienen im Kantenverlag und er beschäftigt sich mit Flüchtlingen, mit unserem Umgang mit Flüchtlingen. Ich bin von diesem Essay nicht rechtslos begeistert. Er ist in der zweiten Hälfte mir zu allgemein, wenn es dann um Klimaflucht und die Gründe für Flucht geht. Und wenn dann so ein bisschen Kapitalismus verquickt wird damit, dass der die Lebensgrundlage uns raubt. Aber es bleibt so sehr allgemein. Also es ist auch gar nicht, dass man dem widersprechen kann. Aber es bleibt so allgemein und auch so altbekannt von dem, was man schon so weiß darüber, dass es mich nicht so umgehauen hat. Ich fand aber die Überlegungen in der ersten Hälfte eigentlich ganz interessant. Denn da wird sich beschäftigt damit, warum eigentlich viele Leute mit so einer Abwehr gegenüber Flüchtlingen auftreten und keine Flüchtlinge haben wollen. Da heißt es, die extremen Reaktionen auf Fluchtbewegungen, die Wellen aus Panik und Euphorie, Hass und Mitleid. Denn es gibt ja auch diese andere Seite, die sagt jetzt, freuen wir uns aber unglaublich am Münchner Hauptbahnhof, wer alles zu uns kommt. Abwehr und Vereinnahmung deuten aber weniger auf eine universelle Wahrheit als vielmehr auf einen neuralgischen Punkt im Selbst- und Weltverhältnis in Europa. Es gibt eine autochtone Fragilität, eine Zerbrechlichkeit der Sesshaften, die durch die Begegnung mit Flüchtenden getriggert wird. Die Zerbrechlichkeit der Sesshaften lässt sich als eine Unterkategorie der Weißen Zerbrechlichkeit verstehen. Was ist jetzt hier mit dieser Zerbrechlichkeit gemeint? Wenn Flüchtlinge kommen oder wir Berichte über Flüchtlinge sehen, so die These, dann sind wir irgendwie gebannt, aber auch verängstigt, weil uns etwas unheimlich vorkommt. Diesen Begriff des Unheimlichen entlehnt der Autor von Freud. Freuds These ist ja, dass uns unheimlich das vor allem erscheint, was wir schon kennen, was aber dann nicht mehr als das Wohlvertraute erscheint, sondern ein bisschen anders ist. Also wenn die Dinge plötzlich merkwürdig werden, wenn die Diener anfängt zu knarzen oder so. Und dieses Unheimliche kann uns auch begegnen, wenn wir uns in anderer leicht verschobener Gestalt da eigentlich sehen, in den Flüchtlingen. Und zwar heißt das dann, die Unheimlichkeit der Flucht ist verbunden mit ihrer Wiederkehr, denn unheimlich kann nur etwas sein, was zuvor vertraut und heimelig war. Die Unheimlichkeit hat ihren Grund nicht in der Andersartigkeit oder Fremdheit der Flüchtenden, sondern vielmehr in ihrer Bekanntheit und ihrer erschreckenden Normalität. Die Flüchtenden sind keine Fremden, sie sind eher entfernte Bekannte. Die Begegnung mit den Flüchtenden ist für die Menschen in Europa nicht deshalb verstörend, weil die Flüchtenden anders sind, sondern weil sie ihnen so ähnlich sind. Und diese Ähnlichkeit, die müssen wir jetzt mal noch definieren. Was ist damit eigentlich gemeint? Europa sieht also jetzt so quasi seine eigenen Gespenster da. Europa sieht auch postapokalyptische Figuren in der Form, die haben das Ende der Welt schon überlebt. Also die sagen, hier ist alles in Schutt und Asche. Ich muss gehen. Also das hier ist schon mal das Welt. Wir wissen, wenn es mit dem Klima so weitergeht, wir werden nicht das Ende der Welt erleben, aber die Zustände werden doch so zu einer Dauerkatastrophe. Also darauf werden wir auch hingewiesen. Und erstmal erfahren wir durch die Ankunft der Flüchtlinge oder durch die Existenz der Flüchtlinge eine Kränkung. Und zwar sollte man das im Sinne von Sigmund Freud, meint er, als eine weitere der großen Kränkungen des Menschen verstehen. Und was sind die Kränkungen? Also die Menschen sind erstens nicht im Zentrum des Universums. Das wissen wir inzwischen. Sie stammen zweitens von Tieren ab und werden drittens durch das Unbewusste gelenkt. Freud sagt ja, man ist nicht her am eigenen Hause. In der Begegnung mit den Flüchtenden müssen sie viertens erkennen, dass ihre Vermögen und ihre Leistungen, ihre Häuser und ihre Aktiendepots, ihre sozialen Beziehungen und ihre Rechte abhängig vom Wohlwollen und Funktionieren des eigenen Staates und der globalen Wertschöpfungsketten sind. Der moderne Mensch ist, und das finde ich ist ein sehr guter Begriff, Staatling, Homo nationalis. Er ist nie her im eigenen Haus. Seine Freiheiten sind nicht grenzenlos. Er ist von der globalen Infrastruktur seines Staates abhängig. Das ist ja auch, glaube ich, das, was man nochmal auch rückbinden kann an diese ganzen Corona-Leugner-Proteste und sowas. Das sind Leute, die plötzlich konfrontiert werden mit der Abhängigkeit vom Staat und drehen plötzlich durch und postulieren für sich eine absolute Freiheit, die es natürlich nicht geben kann, solange man in einem modernen Staat, solange man in einer Gesellschaft lebt. Und dann ist diese Pointe, die Menschen in Europa wehren sich gegen diese Einsicht. Sie wollen keine Staatlinge sein. Und die Flüchtlinge aber zeigen ihnen, guck, man ist als Mensch ein Staatling. Und wenn der Staat einen ganz schlecht behandelt, dadurch, dass Krieg ist oder dass wir hier verhungern, dann muss man fliehen. Und dir kann das grundsätzlich auch so ergehen, denn deine Selbsthaftigkeit ist zwar jetzt gerade gewährleistet, aber das muss nicht für immer sein, sondern der Staat ist natürlich ein Konstrukt. Und diese Überlegung des Staatlings finde ich wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Und der eine Umgang damit ist dann, dass das in Hass umsteckt. Und der andere Umgang ist, davor warnte er allerdings dann auch, ist, dass man dann sich zum Retter aufschwingt, kommt her, wir sind eure großen Helfer. Denn da ist die These von Johannes Siegmund rettende zu sein, gibt ein Gefühl von Kontrolle und Erhabenheit zurück. Das heißt, man versucht dann auch wieder auszuklammern, dass eigentlich Staatling man ist. Und deswegen ist auch dieser Titel in diesem Wir-Sinne wirklich zu verstehen. Der Essay heißt Wir Zukunftslosen, dass wir uns eigentlich als Staatlinge begreifen müssen. Das bedeutet dann auch, die Flüchtlinge als Staatlinge begreifen und da eine Universalität und eine große Gemeinsamkeit drin zu sehen. Also finde ich noch mal ein wichtiger Gedanke.
Der Staatling, also Max Weber, unterscheidet ja ganz scharf zwischen Vergemeinschaftung und Vergesellschaftung. Und ich habe mir das immer so pseudoheuristisch als, ja ja, das eine ist halt die Gemeinschaft, die Kleine, wo man sich kennt und so weiter. Und die Vergesellschaftung ist dann halt dieses große formale Konstrukt, wo man die harten Bretter bohren muss und so. Die dicken Bretter, um da mal was zu ändern. Und der Staatling ist da so ein Versöhnungsding dazwischen, wo sich der einzelne Mensch, der natürlich sich vergemeinschaftet und vergesellschaftet, irgendwie wiederfindet. Und das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Wir haben es ja heute mit Heuristiken, wir haben von Wolkenstein eine schöne Heuristik dargeboten bekommen und den Staatling kann man jetzt auch mal so als Figur irgendwie aufnehmen. Sehr gut. Bleiben wir bei einem, der nirgendwo verortet ist. Weder in Gesellschaft noch in Gemeinschaft, den wir einfach nur auf der Kinoleinwand sehen. Tom Cruise. Wahrscheinlich hast du den Text, ist er dir auch untergekommen.
Nein, ich bin deswegen so gespannt.
Ah, also 54 Books hat über Tom Cruise geschrieben. Und klar, da gibt es dann mal Bücher und so. Deswegen fand ich es auch interessant. Das ist über Tom Cruise. Und ich habe den Text jetzt auch noch mitgebracht, weil zwischendrin ist einfach, deine Pointe ist da kurz aufgegriffen. Auf eine Art und Weise, wie ich es dann doch denke. Okay, du hast die These in den Raum gestellt. Amazon versteht nichts von Fiktion. Das ist ja eine super scharfe These. Und jetzt haben wir aber eine Filmbranche, die halt so ist, wie sie ist. Und die hängt sich natürlich nicht nur im Sachen Film bei Tom Cruise auf, sondern auch in der Beobachtung. Das ist also ein Text über Tom Cruise. Und Tom Cruise fällt für uns ins Auge, weil er sich immer in Lebensgefahr bringt. Und das ist natürlich bei Top Gun Maverick wieder. Er schreibt dann hier Fabius Mailand über den Film, lässt sich sehr wenig und sehr viel sagen. Und das stimmt natürlich, denn wenn man ihn einfach nur als Film ernst nimmt, bleibt fast nichts außer Bilder. Das ist ihm so ganz wichtig, das mal zu sagen. Also Plot und Charaktertiefe oder Charakterentwicklung. All diese Kategorien, das spielt hier alles gar keine Rolle. Es ist im Grunde der letzte große Hollywood-Blackbuster jetzt im Kino, der noch vor der Pandemie gedreht wurde. So wie Tom Cruise hier einige Filme. Es gibt zwei fertig gedrehte Mission Impossible, die jetzt noch kommen. Und dieser Film ist Top Gun Maverick vor der Pandemie gedreht. Jetzt im Kino mit Absicht, eben erst nach der Pandemie im Kino, müsste eigentlich diese Debatte um die Zukunft des Kinos jetzt irgendwie noch mal anheizen. Die Frage, kann man es noch machen? Kann man solche Filme noch machen? Oder arbeiten wir einfach nur noch den fertig gestellten Katalog ab? Und künftig sitzen die Leute halt zu Hause und wollen dann ihre, was weiß ich, kleinen Star Wars Serien in... Wenn man so zu Hause ist, da kann man ja auch gern mal so 4, 5 Stunden. Das ist ja dann nicht so lang. Im Kino wäre es halt so lang. Also haben wir so neue Sehgewohnheiten jetzt. Na ja, wir haben also es hier bei Top Gun Maverick mit einem nicht ganz unwichtigen Film zu tun. Seine Veröffentlichung zum Sommer gehen soll die Frage beantworten, ob sich gigantische Blockbuster-Produktionen für die Kinoleinwand noch lohnen oder nicht. Und dann geht es um die Figur Tom Cruise, die ja das nun alles trägt. Nicht nur als Marketingfigur, sondern eben auch als Hauptdarsteller und so weiter. Und es geht hier um die Oberflächlichkeit, was ich nicht schlecht fand, weil die Leinwand ist nun mal auch oberflächlich. Warum sollte man auf der Leinwand immer so viel Tiefe bringen, wenn es doch nur ums visuelle Bespielen des Publikums geht? Muss man da immer so ein Seminar draus machen und 1000 Fragen aufwerfen? Nö, einfach mal Bilder zeigen. Und nun ist es so, bei diesem Dreh sind die Flugzeuge, und du hast ja auch betont, diese Szenen sind besonders wichtig. Also man sitzt im Kinosaal und fühlt sich wie im Cockpit. Das sind aber diese Momente, in denen dieser Film kein Regisseur braucht. Joseph Kosinski hatte teilweise stundenlang gar keinen Kontakt zu seinen Schauspielern, sondern die wurden vorher instruiert, das ist das Flugzeug, das ist die Kamera, bedient das mal bitte alles gleichzeitig und fliegt hier rum. So, und dann hat man sich halt danach angeschaut, wie das Resultat ist. Aber da ist jetzt nicht irgendwie der Regisseur, der die ganze Zeit hier Anweisungen gibt und das Szenen nochmal wiederholen oder so. Und das fand ich eigentlich, es ist so eine banale Beobachtung, die aber irgendwie so in diesen Zeitraum jetzt passt, wo wir ja feststellen, ja, YouTube, TikTok, und TikTok gräbt ja gerade Netflix wirklich das Wasser ab, indem sie einfach sagen, Regisseure, Budgets, was soll denn der ganze Quatsch? Gebt den Leuten eine Kamera und die machen halt einfach. Da funkt keiner dazwischen. Da gibt es keinen Regisseur, da gibt es kein Drehbuch, sondern so eine Art, wie man halt die Leute da ins Cockpit setzt und sagt, mach einfach mal. Und hoffentlich überzeugt uns das Resultat. Darüber entscheidet spätestens das Publikum. Aber ob ein Regisseur jetzt eine mega große Macht hat, da einfach zu sagen, wir drehen das nächste Woche alles nochmal, ne, hat man dann die Flugzeuge noch und so. Man hat halt diesen einen Versuch, so wie viele YouTuber auch einfach ihren einen Versuch haben. Und dann ist das Ding halt fertig. Naja, dann dieses große Gefühl der Immersion.
Die These ist jetzt, dass der Regisseur obsolet wird, oder was?
Also dieser Film, der gerade die Zukunft des Kinos auf die Probe stellt, zeichnet sich schon dadurch aus, dass er auf relativ viel verzichten kann. Hauptsache die Bilder hauen hin. Aber es ist nicht so sehr der Drehbuchautor oder der Regisseur, sondern es ist dann doch mehr die Technik.
Naja, bei Marvel ist der Regisseur ja zum Beispiel auch nur Erfüllungsgehilfe. Das heißt, einen eigenen Stil kann er da so gut wie nicht unterbringen, sondern der managt das einfach.
Genau, das spielt ja auch gleich nochmal eine Rolle.
Und dann wird das stark aufgeteilt, wer was jetzt dazu zu tun hat. Aber wenn man jetzt von einem Film ausgeht mit einer eigenen Handschrift, dann ist das da nicht mehr zu finden. Und das ist natürlich auch hier zu sehen, dass Top Gun in dem Sinne nicht die eigene Handschrift hat. Was die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Regisseur und Schauspieler anbelangt, ist, dass im amerikanischen Starsystem sowieso sehr viel schwieriger. Also wenn du in Deutschland einen Film drehst, dann gibt der Regisseur den Schauspielern Anweisungen. Das findet bei den Stars oft nicht statt, dass der Regisseur mit den Stars spricht und sagt, mach das noch mal so oder so oder mach mal dieses Gesicht, sondern die haben jeweils ihre Trainer dabei und die erarbeiten mit denen alles. Und dann darf der Regisseur auch dem Trainer noch mal was sagen, in der Hoffnung, dass der das dann umsetzt. Das heißt, es geht immer über diesen Umweg. Das ist eher eine sehr prekäre Position, die der Regisseur da einnimmt.
Na gut, dann, ich hab's ein bisschen flapsig aus dem Text rausgezogen, aber ich fand's so als Beobachtung ganz interessant, dass die Ergebnisse des Filmdrehs in den Momenten, wo sie besonders überwältigend sind, wie hier geschrieben wird, dann hergestellt wurden, als der Schauspieler mit dem Flugzeug und der Kameratechnik auf sich gestellt war. Und diese Auseinandersetzung mit Technologie als sehr viel wichtiger ist, als irgendeine Planung, die man dahinter hat. Diese Szenen sind, ich hab's ja noch nicht gesehen, aber diese Szenen sind anscheinend für sich einfach überzeugend und gut zu sehen, was für eine Handlung darum ist. Ein bisschen wie beim Porno. Man braucht da keine zwingende Handlung oder die muss nicht, kann auch austauschbar sein oder wie auch immer. Man hat es halt so mit Bilderproduktion zu tun. Und was hier am Text auch nochmal betont wird, was mir auch jetzt, ich hab's ja auch schon betont häufiger ist, die Filme schleppen immer so Making-ofs jetzt mit sich, die man sich auf YouTube anschauen kann. Und die meistens sehr viel interessanter sind als der Film selbst. Das ist mir vor allem bei dieser, wie werden eigentlich diese neuen Star-Wars-Serien hergestellt, die einfach auf diesen kleinen Studios mit großer LED-Leinwand und so, wo einfach alles reinprojiziert wird. Und dann ist hier so eine interessante Geschichte, die aufgezogen wird, die Mission Impossible-Filme. Das sind jetzt auch schon über 20 Jahre. Brian De Palma, John Woo, JJ. Abrams werden alle genannt, als die Regisseuren, die es gemacht haben. Und insbesondere dann Brad Bird und Christophe Macquarier, wie auch immer, du weißt wahrscheinlich, wie ausgesprochen wird, die die letzten beiden gemacht haben, kann man durchaus als handwerklich begabt bezeichnen. Aber, wozu braucht man sie eigentlich noch? Die Filme tragen die Schriftzüge von Tom Cruise. Er ist der Schauspieler und der Produzent, er macht die. Und am Ende ist so ein bisschen egal, was man noch drum rumsträgt, welche anderen Figuren es noch gibt. Also es ist alles so auf Tom Cruise. Und Tom Cruise hat es wieder meisterlich irgendwie so hinbekommen, eine Technikgeschichte zu erzählen. Also Tom Cruise ist ein sehr physischer Schauspieler, aber nicht wie Jackie Chan im 1 zu 1 mit anderen Menschen, sondern immer mit Maschinen. Er klettert an Häusern rum, er fliegt diese Flugzeuge, er hängt an Flugzeugen, er springt irgendwo ab, er verlässt sich auf Fallschirme und der ganze Kram, Motorräder und so. Diese Auseinandersetzung, also der Cyborg mit Todestrieb, wird das hier so beschrieben. Das fand ich irgendwie eine gute Beobachtung. Und im freudischen Sinne wird einem hier der Todestrieb nochmal nahe gebracht. Stellvertretend übernimmt dann Tom Cruise für einen den echten Platz im Flugzeug. Aber man fühlt sich, wie du dann eine Filmanalyse sagst, auch im Kinosessel schon wie mit im Cockpit sitzend. Also das ist so eine Stellvertreterei noch mit drin. Und hier im Text wird das nochmal gespiegelt mit Liam Neeson in Taken, der es nicht mal schafft, über einen Zaun zu klettern, sondern da muss es wohl eine legendäre Szene geben, in der in sechs Sekunden 20 Schnitte sind, um zu zeigen, wie er über einen Zaun klettert, während bei Tom Cruise auf totalen Realismus Wert gelegt wird. Dies Action-Szene möglichst ohne Schnitt einfach zu zeigen, wie sie passieren. So Kämpfe, Motorradfahrten, im Gegenverkehr, in Paris und sowas. Das fand ich auch eine gute Beobachtung, dass dieser Bezug auf Körper und Realität sich sehr ähnelt mit dem, was wir auch bei YouTube und TikTok sehen. Körper und irgendwie Realität, aber so unverordbar. Wo findet das statt? Wann fand das statt? Das ist egal. Hauptsache Körper und irgendwie so eine plausible Realität. Und dann zeigt Tom Cruise einfach, was man zu Hause nicht darstellen kann, was auch die TikTok-Kamera durch Tricks nicht bewältigt, sondern dafür muss man dann einfach Tom Cruise für einen Film buchen und ihn da einfach machen lassen. Neben Charaktere, sie werden alle aufgezählt, spielen immer eine kleinere Rolle. Man wollte ja irgendwann den... Find ich seinen Namen hier? Nee, find ich nicht. Aber man hat ja wirklich versucht, Ethan Hunt noch Leute zur Seite zu stellen, die irgendwann auch diesen Film vielleicht mal tragen könnten, falls Tom Cruise mal in der Rolle stirbt. Aber nein, es gibt das wirklich nur um Tom Cruise herum. Und ja, Bilder, Bilder, Bilder. So, und jetzt Bilder und Realität. Tom Cruise ist also besonders, liegt die Realität besonders am Herzen. Und auch eine große Rolle spielt Alter und Tod. Wir haben diese Revival-Welle, also wieder 36 Jahre alt ist ja der Top Gun-Film. Und Tom Cruise will sich natürlich als Alter nicht darstellen, bekommt dann aber Schauspieler zur Seite, Iceman oder so, wie er heißt, Will Kilmer, der dann doch nochmal so körperlichen Verfall zeigt.
Und die Filmpartnerin wurde ja ausgetauscht. Also man hat nicht jetzt einfach nochmal die Liebesgeschichte aufgewärmt aus dem ersten Top Gun, sondern man hat jetzt gesagt, naja, man kann ja Tom Cruise jetzt nicht mit einer gleichaltrigen Frau zeigen. Also man kann ja nicht da jetzt eine 58-Jährige, das war irgendwie nicht klar. Und dann meinte auch die Schauspielerin selbst, ich habe gerade ihren Namen vergessen, dass sie zu alt gewesen sei, also auch äußerlich zu alt, deswegen hätte man sie nicht mehr gebucht. Und jetzt hat ja Tom Cruise eine andere Frau an seiner Seite in Top Gun, wo geflirtet wird und dann gibt es dann auch so eine kleine Liebeszene, die aber recht stümperhaft umgesetzt ist. Jedenfalls ist hier ganz deutlich versucht man also mit einer jüngeren Frau und auch jungen aussehenden Frau natürlich auch den Tom Cruise mitzuverjüngen.
So, und da ist aber jetzt ein Problem, denn diese Filme laufen über Tom Cruise. Tom Cruise ist aber ein echter Mensch, auch wenn wir über den nichts weiter wissen. Der altert in seiner Rolle, aber auch als echter Mensch. Und mit ihm alle, die auch Rollen spielen, gerade bei Mission Impossible, hat er da so ein Team, das schleppt er ja mit über die Filme hinweg. Und hier kommt einfach der Zuschauer nicht mehr umhin, doppelgleisig zu fahren. Das ist eben nicht nur im Film thematisiert, die werden älter, sondern die sind einfach als Schauspieler auch älter. Und darüber schlägt sich ja nun diese Frage, wie du sie eben aufgeworfen hast, bei irgendeiner weiblichen Bekanntschaft. Kann man jetzt eine tatsächlich gealterte Frau einfach da mit in den Film bringen? Nein, es muss dann eine Jüngere sein. Und das fällt dann aber auch auf, das ist dann Thema. Wenn da einfach aus filmexternen Gründen intern der Film anders ist, weil eine alte Frau kann man ja nicht zeigen. So, dieses Altern spielt also eine besondere Rolle und er kommt dann nochmal auf die besonderen merkwürdigen Umgänge, zum Beispiel im Star Wars-Universum. Also Carrie Fisher ist schon tot und spielt trotzdem noch in Filmen mit. Oder Mark Hamill wird nochmal total verjüngt dargestellt. Also dass man da einfach so technisch trickst, was dann eben bei Tom Cruise nicht stattfindet. Und trotzdem stellt sich die Frage, kann man das Alter der Schauspieler außen vor lassen? Oder übertreibt man es und baut dann halt so Drehbücher und sagt, nicht nur das Alter ist wichtig, sondern auch die geschlechtliche Orientierung oder was auch immer. Dass man das halt wirklich in die Filme rein importiert, obwohl es eigentlich externe Rolle spielt. Das Marketing spielt aber auch wieder etwas externer Rolle. Also kann man es gar nicht richtig davon raushalten, gerade nicht bei solchen großen Produktionen. Und in Twin Peaks ist es wohl so, dass die Realität, die eben nicht oder dass die Fiktion, die eben nicht nur einfach Realität sein oder die Fiktion, die einfach nur nicht nicht Realität sein gelassen werden kann. Ich hoffe, du kannst mir folgen. Also man braucht ein bisschen Realität, auch in der Fiktion.
Ja, ja, es gibt diese starke Realismus-Auslegung beim Film. Also da kommt man auch nicht ganz raus. Es ist nicht wie auf einer Theaterbühne, wo man viel mehr mit Behauptungen arbeiten kann.
Genau, es sind die Schauspieler, die man auch irgendwie kennt, auch aus anderen Zusammenhängen, die man wiedererkennt und so. Und in Twin Peaks hat er jetzt eine dritte Staffel bekommen, was auch wieder so als, ja, wir schließen mal eine Folge früher an. Und Lynch konnte sich das ein bisschen austoben. Und da gibt es eine Figur, Lock Lady, die 2015 an Krebskomplikation verstarb, die aber in, also die Schauspielerin Katharine E. Coulson spielt, aber noch mit. Und zwar selbst fünf Tage vor ihrem tatsächlichen Tod noch mit einem Satz wie Hawkeye im Dying, der so kontextlos einfach stattfindet. Also in der Serie sagt sie als Figur zu einer anderen Figur, ich sterbe hier gerade und fünf Tage später ist sie aber wirklich als Schauspielerin gestorben. Also David Lynch hat es hier sozusagen richtig auf die Spitze getrieben. Und Fiktion und Realität mal so richtig verschränkt. Und gleichsam ist die erste Folge dieser Twin Peaks Staffel der Schauspielerin gewidmet und die letzte Folge dem Charakter. Also so, dass man auch auf beiden Ebenen da nochmal die, und da fragt man sich ja eh, die Widmung steht ja am Anfang. Ist das dann noch die Botschaft des, oder ist es schon, also hat es dann schon begonnen, die Fiktion, oder sind wir da noch in der Realität? Ja, so ein bisschen, und da hab ich dann doch irgendwie gedacht, hm, vielleicht kann man es doch nicht so einfach sagen, dass Fiktion einfach nicht die Realität ist, sondern gerade in der Filmproduktion heute, da doch noch so ein paar Verschränkungen drin sind. Also, dass...
Sie können sein, also eine Sichtbarmachung ist natürlich da von Nöten oder Transparenzmachung, wo man es mit Fragen des Alters zu tun hat. Also entweder sagt man, man lässt jetzt dann nur noch Cybox auftreten oder man lässt Tom Cruise animieren. Also man könnte ihn jetzt auch als ewig 30-jährigen animieren lassen. Im Prinzip könnte Tom Cruise sagen, ich drehe nicht mehr selbst Filme, sondern vermisst mich noch mal bitte. Und dann arbeitet er mit den entsprechenden Computerprogrammen, um mich ewig jung auf der Leinwand zu lassen. Es gibt ja einen nicht besonders guten Billy Wilder Film dazu, der heißt Fedora. Und da ist die Pointe, dass Fedora eine Leinwandgöttin ist, die wunderschön ist, aber nicht altern will. Und dann muss irgendwann die Tochter von Fedora Fedora sein. Und die bricht dann zerbricht natürlich dann daran, gespielt von Hildegard Knef. Ursprünglich sollte die Rolle Marlene Dietrich übernehmen, die aber keine alte Frau spielen wollte in den 70er Jahren, wo sie selbst schon weit über 70 war. Und natürlich kommt man da an so einem Punkt an, wo die Realität in den Film hinein ragt. Ich glaube, bei diesem Amazon Playbook geht es einfach darum, dass es um geschlechtliche Identität und solche Sachen geht. Und wo ich sage, das ist vollkommener Unsinn. Genauso auch, was nationale Herkunft anbelangt. Also natürlich muss auch da an einem Realismus entsprochen werden. Also auf der Theaterbühne kann jemand 20 Jahre alt sein und sagen, ich bin King Lear und dann glauben wir das. Oder es kann auch eine Frau sein, die sagt, ich bin King Lear, dann glauben wir das auch. Das ist im Film so nicht möglich. Also muss da irgendetwas schon entsprechend äußerlich da sein, dass man sagt, ein King Lear müsste ein Mann sein und müsste auch ein entsprechendes Alter haben, weil der ja drei Töchter hat. Und da klebt man also am Realismus dran. Das bedeutet aber natürlich jetzt nicht, dass nur der schwule Schauspieler eine schwule Figur spielen kann. Und das sind ja solche Ideen, die man da hat. Oder dass man nur den eigenen Kulturkreis verkörpern darf oder so einen Unsinn. Also natürlich geht Black Facing nicht. Aber wenn ich jetzt Schauspieler wäre und würde in Spanien spielen, wäre das wahrscheinlich auch nicht so problematisch. Würde man hinkriegen auf der Leinwand. Ohne dass es auffällt. Aber ich kann jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht einen 12-Jährigen spielen. Das ginge jetzt nicht.
Genau. Und das ist interessant, weil manche Merkmale sind eben sichtbar und manche nicht. Und wenn es um die Bilderproduktion geht, spielt Alter eine Megarolle und sexuelle Orientierung eben gar keine. Weil die ist halt nicht sichtbar. Wenn du in Spanien spielen sollst, ist es wieder eine Herausforderung für Maskenbildnerei und so weiter oder auch Training.
Wenn man sagt, dass Spanien so... Man muss ja auch aufpassen, dass man da nicht wieder in so einen neuen Tribalismus verfällt. Aber das wäre jetzt möglich. Ich könnte auch in Franzosen spielen oder so. Ja, also das ist keine... Ich glaube, dass das so eine ganz eigenartige Verengung ist. Aber da wird eigentlich dann Kulturpolitik gemacht. Ich glaube, das geht ja gar nicht auf so einer ästhetischen Ebene. Aber die Fragen, die sich hier durch das Altern aufwerfen, das ist ja was ganz, ganz Eigenartiges, weil der Film Momente band für die Ewigkeit und jeder, der einen Film gedreht hat, wird zum Untoten. Weil die Leinwand einen auf ewig Jung festhält und man selbst aber altert. Es ist also die umgekehrte Dorian Gray-Variante. Bei Dorian Gray ist es so, das Bild altert und man selbst bleibt jung. Und beim Film ist es genau umgekehrt. Und das ist für die Stars, die vor allem auf ihr Äußeres und ihre Jugendlichkeit angelegt sind, so ein großes Problem. Das ist ja kein Problem für einen Robert Redford zum Beispiel. Robert Redford ist immer gealtert, sieht auch gut aus. Also ist gut gealtert, aber ist keineswegs so, dass man ihn ansieht und denkt, oh, der möchte aber eigentlich gerne 20 Jahre jünger sein.
Der wurde allerdings auch als Brad Pitt wiedergeboren und hat damit so einen gewissen Vorteil, dass es ihn einfach zweimal gibt, in etwas jünger und älter. Auch Top Gun konnte sich nicht ganz dagegen wehren. Sie wollten Wilkill mal nochmal auf der Leinwand zeigen mit Kehlkopfkrebs und auch mit seiner eigenen Stimme, die ja früher mal sehr prägnant war und eben auch diesem SS-Zeit loszulassen. Ein Hinweis, den Iceman dem Maverick gibt, auf den Maverick hört, aber Tom Cruise eben nicht. Also er hält weiter daran fest, diese Rolle da zu spielen. Man hier nochmal gut gespiegelt. Und in der Hinsicht ist Top Gun weniger radikal bei dieser Auslegung Fiktion-Realität als eben Twin Peaks, die es da wirklich auf die Spitze getrieben haben. Und der Text handelt dann auch nochmal davon, wie sich die Studios unabhängig machen von ihren Schauspielern, von denen sie so abhängig sind. Tom Cruise ist so bankable im Sinne von Bank, Geld und so an Angelegenheiten, dass die ganze Schicksalshaftigkeit eines Films davon abhängt, ist es jetzt Tom Cruise, der die Rolle spielt oder nicht, während. Und das ist eine super Beobachtung hier gewesen, die natürlich total offen da liegt, aber man kann sie natürlich mal aussprechen. Tom Cruise hat, weil er Tom Cruise ist, keinen Platz im Marvel-Universum. Es wäre undenkbar, dass er in einem Marvel-Film mitspielt. Das würde alles durcheinanderbringen und die Leute ablenken und fragen, was soll das jetzt und so. Und gleichzeitig, obwohl Tom Cruise so wichtig ist für die Filmbranche und jetzt über die Schicksalshaftigkeit, das postkronische Schicksal mitentscheidet, war niemals ein Tom Cruise so erfolgreich, wie die Marvel-Filme für sich erfolgreich sind. Also die Studios haben es irgendwie hinbekommen, zu sagen, wir haben hier eine Idee im Mittelpunkt. Und wenn wir sagen, das ist ein Marvel-Film, können wir da auch ganz neue Schauspieler reinpacken oder die eh als Team aufstellen. Wenn dann mal einer fehlt, ist auch nicht so schlimm. Also die haben sich wirklich ein bisschen unabhängig gemacht davon. Und wir können da eben all in gehen, was einfach diese Themen- und Plot-Entwicklung wieder angeht. Oder eben auch einfach nur, du hast ja die Zahl genannt, 4.000 Charaktere gibt es da bei Marvel. Wir haben also so eine Konzentration auf die Schauspieler hier und dann irgendwie dieses stimmungsmäßige, hier tauchst du in eine Welt ein, das ist hier Marvel, da sind 40 Filme, guckst du dir eine chronologische Reihenfolge an, vielleicht findest du noch irgendwelche Sinnstrukturen und so. Also klar, da geht es auch um Bilder und so weiter, aber ein bisschen abseits davon und vor allem nicht so realistisch dargestellte Action, sondern einfach nur Action, viel Greenscreen, ja, lange und so. Und dann kommt, weil der Text ja mit Tom Cruise begann, haben sie hier eine ganz wunderbare Pointe. Du fandest ja Fury Road, glaube ich, auch einen guten Film, ne? So, und jetzt steht hier, und das fand ich wirklich gut beobachtet, Fury Road ist auch ein Film über Mensch-Maschinen, wie das, was Tom Cruise immer macht, der jedoch vor allem auf der horizontalen Ebene spielt, mit einer Eleganz, die man flapsig zusammenfassen kann. Ein Autokonvoi fährt zwei Akte lang in die eine Richtung, dreht um und fährt dann im dritten Akt wieder zum Ausgangspunkt. Die vertikale Dimension gehört fast ganz allein den Action-Film von Tom Cruise mit Flugzeugen, Helikoptern und Saugnäpfen. Also man schreibt einen Text über Tom Cruise, mit allem Auseinandersetzung mit der Maschine, dieser Konzentration auf die Figur, bei der man immer nicht genau weiß. Schaut man das wegen Tom Cruise, weil er so ein toller Schauspieler hat, egal was er Schauspieler hat, oder kommt es dann auf die Rollen an, will man eigentlich Ethan Hawke sehen, kann das auch ein jemand anderes sein. Und dann sagt man, der Tom Cruise macht das schon ziemlich gut. Das ist absolut überzeugende Bilder und darüber hinaus aber nichts. Aber worum geht es im Kino? Um Bilder, um mal so einen Bogen, also diesen Weg mal zu gehen. Und dann eben kein Film von Tom Cruise ist wohl so gut wie die einzig ernsthafte Big Budget Stunt Konkurrenz der letzten Jahre Mad Max Fury Road. Also das ist ein Film, der wirklich nur Autos, die fahren, zeigen. Hier inhaltlich nochmal alles, was Tom Cruise geleistet hat. Auch an, wir machen hier eine Geschichte auf, die nicht nur für einen Film trägt, sondern für viele und so weiter. Und wir entwickeln dann zumindest den Ethan Hunt und so. Dass man hier dann einfach einen Film, wo man nur einmal nach links fährt und einmal wieder nach rechts fährt, und das auch noch so dispektierlich sagt, meint, also das toppt dann aber qualitativ wirklich die ganze Tom Cruise- Schaffensgeschichte von 40, 50 Jahren, ist schon eine ziemlich starke Pointe, fand ich. Ich musste gestern so ein bisschen drüber lachen.
Ja, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Ich will noch ein Beispiel geben für die Realität, die in den Film hinein ragt. Und ganz kompliziert wird es, wenn auch noch Fiktionen aus anderen Filmen, also wenn andere fiktionale Werke in fiktionale Werke hineinreichen und alles überlagern. Und zwar gibt es ja den Film Halloween Age 20. Den hast du vielleicht mal gesehen. 1998 kam der raus. Also Halloween ist ja dieser uralte Film aus den, was heißt uralte, aus den 70er Jahren. Jamie Lee Curtis, die ist ja das ewige Final Girl. Das heißt, sie wird nicht von Michael erstochen und lebt dann in den Fortsetzungen weiter. Und 1998 macht man dann 20 Jahre nach dem ersten Teil wieder einen Film, der heißt Halloween Age 20. Nun ist Jamie Lee Curtis nicht nur das berühmte Final Girl, das dann da wieder auftaucht und natürlich dann anknüpft an all das, sondern sie ist auch die Tochter von Janet Leigh. Und Janet Leigh war das Mordopfer in Hitchcocks Psycho. Also sie war nicht das Final Girl, sie hat nicht überlebt. Nun spielt aber Janet Leigh in diesem Film mit. Und zwar spielt sie die Mutter von Jamie Lee Curtis, aber die Filmmutter dann. Und dann unterhalten sich Mutter und Tochter im Film miteinander. Aber als Filmfiguren sind sie auch Mutter und Tochter. Und dann sagt die Mutter quasi so etwas, dass man manchmal im Leben Schlimmes erfährt, aber dass man irgendwie vielleicht auch damit umgehen kann. Und da spricht aber eigentlich ein Opfer aus dem Hitchcock-Film, die das kennt, die das weiß, wie das ist, wenn man von einem Wahnsinnigen verfolgt wird, zu der Filmtochter. Und da überlagert sich dann alles. Also da sieht man, wie man auch in der Popkultur natürlich mit all dem spielen kann. Und das macht den Film natürlich so interessant.
Ja, das ist natürlich witzig, weil du da nicht nur aus dem Film heraus in die Realität rast, sondern wieder in eine andere Fiktion hinein. Aber zwischendurch ist ja dieser Brückenschlag, irgendwo zwischendurch ist ein bisschen Realität über die Schauspieler, die schon Werdengänger und so. Naja, das ist verdreht. Das sind dann die Schmankel für dich. Die stehen dann bestimmt alle in deinem Buch so drin.
Vielleicht. Mal schauen.
Vielleicht, du verrätst nichts.
Ich verrate nichts. Ich komme zu einem Roman, den ich gelesen habe, Die Kinder sind Könige. Und zwar handelt dieser Roman von einer Mutter, die zwei Kinder hat und einen Lebensgefährten, eine Tochter Kimi und einen Sohn Sammy. Und diese Mutter kommt irgendwann auf die Idee, es ist so langweilig hier zu Hause. Ich könnte ja mal anfangen, die sozialen Medien zu nutzen. Sie fängt dann erst so bei Facebook an. Man muss sagen, das wird dann kapitelweise immer so ein bisschen nacherzählt, wie es dazu gekommen ist. Jedenfalls schafft sie es, ein richtiges Medieninfluencer-Imperium aufzuziehen. Also ihre Kinder haben eigene YouTube-Kanäle dann sehr bald und sie auch. Und dann gibt es Familienkanäle. Jedenfalls haben die eine Millionenreichweite. Und der Roman beginnt aber damit, dass Kimi, also die kleine Tochter, sechs, sieben Jahre alt, plötzlich nicht mehr da ist. Sie ist entführt worden. Und dann gibt es eine Kommissarin mit dem Namen Clara, die zu dieser Melanie, dieser Influencer-Mutter fährt, und das versucht, den Fall aufzurollen, die das also betrachtet, was ist da eigentlich los. In Frankreich gibt es schon viel stärker im Übrigen diese Debatte, wie man Kinder eigentlich da schützen sollte im Internet vor dieser Kommerzialisierung und so. Wir werden da auch sehr wahrscheinlich in der nächsten Folge nochmal drauf zu sprechen kommen. Und dies ist jetzt also quasi ein Roman, der sich auch mit dieser Debatte auseinandersetzt. Denn diese Kommissarin, die vollzieht jetzt erst mal nach, was geschieht da eigentlich, und beschreibt dann die Videos, die sie sieht. Es gibt Verhöre. Wer könnte hinter dieser Entführung stehen? Ist das vielleicht der Ex-Mann oder so? Aber diese üblichen Spuren, die zerschlagen sich. Es gibt auch Protestbewegungen, Aktivisten gegen dieses Kinderinfluenzertum. Und dieser Roman ist anfangs sehr zäh. Und man hat vor allem den Eindruck, es ist so ein bisschen, als würde man einen Tatort sehen, der sich jetzt mal dem Thema Kinderinfluenzermissbrauch im digitalen Zeitalter und sowas annimmt. Also man hat so ein Konzeptpapier und sagt dann zwei Drehbuchautoren, schreibt mal was auf. Und dann hat der Roman aber doch zunehmend seine Qualitäten, wenn er eigentlich diese wahnsinnig aseptische, zwischen Konsum und Challenges eingehegte Welt betrachtet. Und auch wenn versucht wird, eigentlich anhand der Videos, die sich die Kommissarin ansehen, Rückschlüsse zu ziehen, wie geht es diesen Kindern eigentlich, weil die sich natürlich nicht in einer Weise darüber äußern können, mit sechs, sieben oder acht Jahren. Und da heißt es dann an einer Stelle, die ich mal länger zitieren werde, klarer schaut sich also die Kommissarin wieder diese Videos an. Aus dieser Bilderfolge ging eines ganz klar hervor. In den letzten Wochen hatte sich Kimmys Haltung verändert. Manchmal war es nur ein Detail, ein Gesichtsausdruck des Kindes, ein Zurückweichen der Ansatz zu einer Bewegung, um der Kamera auszuweichen. Doch in anderen Augenblicken war nicht zu übersehen, dass es dem kleinen Mädchen nicht gut ging. Mehrmals hätte Clara sie am liebsten in die Arme genommen, sie aus dem Bild gezogen, sie daraus geholt. Immer häufiger schützte sich Kimmi mit ihrer Kapuze oder wandte der Kamera den Rücken zu. Während Sammy seinen Mann zu stehen, versuchte Reflexartiges Lächeln, zustimmend in die Höhe direkter Daumen. Kimmi aber schien verschwinden zu wollen. Angesichts dieser Bilder hätte Clara am liebsten gesagt, aufhören und alles ausgestellt. Sie ließ das Programm weiterlaufen und Melanies Stimme erfüllte wieder den Raum. Clara beobachtete das Mädchen auf dem Bildschirm, sie ließ es nicht aus den Augen. In einer Story vom Ende des Sommers, die bei Optik Future aufgenommen worden war, ließ Melanie, also die Mutter, ihre Abonnenten darüber abstimmen, welche Brille Sammy kaufen sollte. Sie fragte auch Kimi nach ihrer Meinung, doch die kleine, die sichtlich erschöpft auf einem Stuhl saß, antwortete nicht mehr. Sofort nach Verlassen des Geschäfts teilte Melanie das Ergebnis der Abstimmung mit. Dank des guten Rats ihrer Lieben hatte das Jaccardi-Modell den Sieg davongetragen. Sammy lächelte in die Kamera, während Kimi im Hintergrund stand und ins Leere starte. Nach einigen Sekunden begriff sie, dass sie von der Kamera erfasst wurde und versteckte mit einer Erschöpfung und übertrussverratenden Bewegung ihr Gesicht. An jenem Tag schien Kimi ihren Rücktritt erklärt zu haben, ihre Unfähigkeit, das Spiel mitzuspielen, zu lächeln und so zu tun, als ob. Und da hat der Roman wirklich seine Stärke, wenn versucht wird, diese Art der Kinderarbeit so würde ich das ja durchaus nennen, zu beschreiben, die da jetzt millionenfach Klicks generiert. Wir haben ja in Deutschland mit den Kinderinfluencern auch so ein riesiges Phänomen. Und das finde ich schon ganz interessant, wie dann mit literarischen Mitteln das nochmal eingefangen wird. Auch ist es ganz interessant, dass es ein Schlussteil des Buches gibt, etwa so 80 Seiten, die dann nach vorne springen, aus der Pandemie und all dem heraus ins Jahr 2031. Und dann nochmal guckt, was aus denen geworden ist. Ich halte es nicht für einen rundumgeglückten Roman. Ich hätte mir mehr gewünscht, dass man anhand solcher Beschreibungen, also literarisch aufzeigt, was da passiert. Zum Teil hat das Buch etwas sehr didaktisches, dass man so den Eindruck hat, der Autorin ist es ein unglaubliches Anliegen, Delfine de vegan heißt sie, darauf hinzuweisen, dass da ganz schlimme Zustände herrschen, dass da Kinder unter einen enormen Druck gesetzt werden, dass sie täglich arbeiten müssen, dass sie ewig in der Öffentlichkeit stehen. Und dabei ist so ein bisschen das Literarische mitunter abhanden gekommen.
Also ich weiß damals, weil es mir direkt berichtet wurde, dass die IG Metall aufmerksam wurde auf gewisse Ideologien, die die Arbeitswelt im Silicon Valley vorantreiben, weil Dave Eggert damals The Circle geschrieben hat und wir das in der FAZ besprachen. Und dann haben die da gleich so Arbeitsgruppen, also Themen verteilt, um das sich auch mal anzuschauen. In der Hinsicht sind solche Bücher, gerade wenn sie so ein bisschen didaktisch um die Ecke kommen, vielleicht finden die da so ein Publikum.
Das kann sein. Bei Elgas ist das ja auch der Fall. Und bei Elgas würde ich auch sagen, das interessiert mich literarisch relativ wenig.
Genau, das wird ihm ja häufig unterstellt. Auf der anderen Seite hat er ja nun doch mit dieser kleinen, herzzureißenden Geschichte der Titelliste kompliziert. Die kriegen wir nicht zusammen über seine Familie da.
Aber ich lese dann wirklich lieber einen Ruf von Yvonne Hofstetter oder Shoshana Zuboff. Das ist dann für mich am Ende interessanter.
Gut, mein letzter Text, wenn ich mich nicht erzählt habe, aber ich glaube ich nicht, ist die E-Mail von Alex, die er uns schrieb, nachdem ich im Fernsehpodcast-Scot sagte, Dorel I habe ich ja noch nie gehört, was ist denn das? Und er dann die Hinweise gab und ich das letzte Mal über Lambda sprach, also diesen Textgenerator, der ja angeblich empfindungsfähig ist, weil das der diskordianische Priester, der bei Google arbeitet, behauptet hat und so weiter und so fort. Und Dali ist nun super interessant, weil das ähnlich mit Bildern gemacht wird. Und wir eben schon das letzte Mal gesagt haben, ja, da wird halt wirklich in so ein ökonomisches Gefüge eingegriffen, Stockfotografie zum Beispiel. Nicht nur, dass man den Markt übernimmt, sondern auch wirklich innerlich revolutioniert. Und Dali, also D-A-L-L minus E, also Warli, aber Dali sind dann immer so Abkürzungen, die man natürlich alles verspielt, dann irgendwie nutzt, ist ein Projekt von der Open-AI-Ink. Das ist eine Firma betrieben von Elon Musk und Microsoft, die sich da zusammentaten. Ich habe noch im Hinterkopf, wie Elon Musk mal sagte...
Die arbeiten da zusammen, obwohl ja Elon Musk und Bill Gates so zerstritten sind, beziehungsweise Elon Musk Bill Gates beleidigt hat und Bill Gates beleidigt wurde von Elon Musk, weil er wohl auf Short gegangen ist, was die Tesla-Aktie oder so anbelangte und sagte, ja, da glaube ich nicht dran. Und da sind also dann zwei sehr egozentrische Menschen aufeinander getroffen.
Ja, ich würde halt sagen, Microsoft und Bill Gates hat gar nicht mehr so viel miteinander zu tun, außer die Vermögenssachen schon seit Jahrzehnten eigentlich. Und ich habe irgendwann mal gelesen, ich glaube, das betrifft dann auch dieses Unternehmen, dass Elon Musk einfach nur, damals hieß es noch, mit Mark Zuckerberg zusammen so eine künstliche Intelligenzfirma betreibt, nur um einfach zu wissen, was da los ist in der Branche. Also so als Hobby nebenher, um da nicht völlig außen vor zu sein. Vielleicht ist das dieses Projekt, keine Ahnung. Aber die haben jetzt dieses Story im Januar 2021 vorgestellt, also nach einem Jahr Corona. Es ist so eine ganz interessante Corona-Geschichte von der Joscha Bach, der da glaube ich in Harvard sitzt und immer auch für die Deutschen so ein paar Vorträge hält, im Umfeld des KS Computer Clubs, sich da ein bisschen auskennt, auch mit so Ideen-Geschichten und so. Meint, diese Entwicklungssprünge, die da jetzt gerade stattfanden, sind wirklich sehr beeindruckend. DOLI 2 insbesondere. Also nach Januar 2021 gab es seit die Tage ein Update. Und das Projekt ist, man macht aus Bildunterschriften Bilder. Also man gibt einen Text vor, verschiedene Substantive, die werden dann in Bilddatenbanken gesucht und kombiniert. Aber die Kombination der unterschiedlichen Gegenstände ist halt selber eine Bildsynthese, bei der man im Nachhinein nicht mehr feststellen soll, dass das mal nicht zusammen auf einem Bild gehört ist, sondern es soll aussehen wie eine Fotografie. Oder es völlig übertreiben und eben Obst und Farbe so kombinieren, dass dann wirklich das Obst eine andere Farbe hat. Oder ein Möbelstück aussieht wie keine Ahnung. Und ich nenne noch mal Obst aus Ideenlosigkeit. Aber solche Sachen, dass man so Konzepte miteinander verbindet.
Gibt es also eine Datenbank, die richtige Fotos hat?
Genau.
Also gibt es irgendwas Echtes, was kompiliert wird? Oder ist die Grundlage in dem Sinne auch gar nicht da?
Genau, die Grundlage sind Bilder, die mit Bildunterschriften einfach geliefert wurden. Und dann möglichst ein Objekt zeigen. Also Flugzeuge, tausendfach Flugzeuge aus allen Richtungen, fotografiert und so weiter. So, dass dann selbst gelernt festgestellt wird, aha, das ist ein Flugzeug. Und so werden auch alle anderen Sachen gelernt. Und dann ist es die Aufgabe, das zu kombinieren. Also wenn jemand sagt, zeig mir ein Flugzeug, das aussieht wie eine Gurke, dann wird eben der Flugzeugrumpf mit der Oberfläche einer Gurke kombiniert und solche Sachen. Also, dass man da so richtig generieren kann. Es sind, um diese Zahlen zu nennen, 12 Milliarden Parameter, die da hintereinander weg gelernt wurden und abgeklappert werden, diese Konzepte zu verstehen, diese Bildverarbeitung zu bewerkstelligen. Es werden pro Suche, die gemacht werden, oder pro Generierungsauftrag immer mehrere Ergebnisse geliefert, sodass dann auch wieder die Auswahl, was hat den Menschen am besten gefallen, wiederum zurückgekoppelt wird, um dann für spätere Prozesse zu lernen und so weiter. Naja, dieses Dolly-Zeug war so beeindruckend, als die Leute das sahen. Man kann es noch nicht selber verwenden. Dafür ist wahrscheinlich die Rechenkraft noch zu hoch. Aber man sieht Beispielbilder, die aus dem Apparat rausfielen. Und da dachten sich so einige Leute, krass. Also diese milliardenschwere Stock-Fotografie-Branche. Und man will ja für alles irgendeine Bebilderung haben im Internet, damit das auch alles schön attraktiv ist. Die liegt jetzt einfach da nieder. Also das braucht jetzt einfach keiner mehr. Man sagt einfach, ich brauche ein Büro, fünf Stühle, drei Leute, die sich anlächeln. Und dann kriegt man einfach so ein Bild generiert. Man muss da auf keine weiteren, da sind aber Persönlichkeitsrechte oder sowas, Rücksicht nehmen, weil diese Menschen sind generiert und so. Und dann ist das halt wirklich so eine neue Möglichkeit, für Attraktivität im Internet zu sorgen, ohne dass man auf diese ganzen Sachen da Rücksicht nehmen muss. Alex hat uns das alles hier mal so aufgeschlüsselt und verweist dann auch noch mal auf Google Imagine heißt das. Wozu Alex schreibt, dann kam vor ein paar Tagen noch einmal Google mit ihrer KI, mit einer anderen Technik heraus, was das auch wieder geschlagen hat. Also die Leute waren dann noch mal beeindruckt von Googles Ergebnissen als von dem, was Dol i macht. Und da gibt es auch von Google selbst, imagine.research.google, eine Seite, wo man so ein bisschen rumspielen kann und sich das anschauen kann. Also so langsam öffnet sich es auch für die Allgemeinheit. Und dann gab es hier eben ein Tweet an Joscha Bach. Ich freue mich auf die Zeit, in der Dol i 10.2 in der Lage sein wird, Filme auf Hollywood-Niveau zu produzieren, indem man einfach ganze Bücher eingibt, wäre das möglich. Also man gibt ein Drehbuch mit Regieanweisungen und Szenariebeschreibungen, Kulissen und lässt dann einfach mal generieren. So klar, das ist jetzt die Anfangszeit. Erst mal sind es nur Bilder und so. Warum nicht Bewegtbilder? Es ist ja alles möglich. Es ist ja nur eine Frage der Rechenkraft dann. Und dann schreibt Bach darauf, es scheint unvermeidlich, sie brauchen kein Buch einzugeben, denn es kennt die meisten vorhandenen Bücher und kann neue Bücher zu fast jedem Thema und für jedes Publikum schreiben, das sie wollen. Also was wäre, wenn man jetzt wirklich Lambda nimmt, diesen Textgenerator, der ja nun, wie wir gehört haben, den Menschen sehr gut kennt, ihm also vorgaukeln kann, irgendwie sentimental zu sein, Gefühle zu haben, nur weil einfach klar ist, ja, so ist Literatur halt aufgebaut. Die suggeriert das. Wir wissen ja, wenn wir ins Kino gehen, das ist Fiktion. Und trotzdem sind wir emotional überwältigt, wenn es gut läuft. So, und was wäre denn, wenn jetzt wirklich die Maschine aufgrund dieser Textanalyse, die sie schon hat, Drehbücher generiert, die dann von Doll Imagine, wie auch immer, umgesetzt werden? Man kann ja mit Kurzfilm anfangen, eine Minute Instagram-Content oder sowas, ne?
Ich hatte ja im vergangenen Salon das Buch von Amanda Lotz vorgestellt, wie eigentlich Netflix funktioniert. Und da sagte sie, die gehen jetzt nicht auf Zielgruppe, dass die sagen, ah, Stefan ist ein Mann, so und so alt, und deswegen interessiert er sich für dies und das, sondern die wissen, was du gesehen hast, und haben dann solche Muster und haben vor allem Keywords, oder sie nimmt dann einen anderen Begriff, die vor allem auch die Emotionen, die geweckt werden, damit verbunden sind und die Stimmung, also die Atmosphäre, das Iron, das ist ironisch, das ist lustig, das ist melancholisch. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, man hätte all diese Daten von dir, also das hast du alles gesehen, diese Geschichten kennst du. Außerdem sind diese Emotionen dir wichtig, dieser Tonfall wäre interessant. Dann könnte man auf diese Weise und mit entsprechender Rechenleistung sicherlich irgendetwas generieren. Aber das ist natürlich furchtbar.
Aber wir wissen ja, Kindle und Amazon Prime Video und auch Netflix, die werten ja Nutzerverhalten radikal aus.
Ja, weil es ist ja doch auch noch nicht der AI-Roman geschrieben, der zum Bestseller geworden wurde.
Genau, und das ist eben dieser Punkt.
Zum Bestseller gekommen ist bzw. man kann wahrscheinlich eher so beobachten, dass Autoren versuchen, so zu schreiben, wie eine AI, die alle Daten hat, schreiben würde.
Also die Google-Suche als aller einfachstes und von uns allen bekanntes System, das uns unsere Bedürfnisse befriedigt, inhaltlicher Art. Und wir reden ja nur über audiovisuelle Bedürfnisse, die wir haben, wenn wir über Tom Cruise usw. reden und die Bilderwelten. Man gibt ein Suchwort ein und Google sucht dann aus dem Index, den sie haben, einfach so 10.000 Ergebnisse zusammen. Und zeigen uns aber fünf ausgewählte als die ersten und drei besonders hervorgehoben. Und dann gucken sie genau, was wird denn von dem angeklickt. Man braucht also nicht nur das Weltwissen, sondern auch wissen darüber, wie die Nutzer es nutzen. Google wollte ja immer alle Bücher der Welt und wissen darüber, wie die Leute lesen, was sie lesen haben. So, jetzt ist es natürlich immer noch ein Einschlag der Verlegenheit, zu sagen, gestalte mir ein Bild mit einem Schreibtisch und einer Lampe und einem Baum mitten drauf und lass bitte Gras drunter wachsen. Und dann gibt es halt 12 Vorschläge von der Maschine. Also sie ist immer noch sehr dabei zu lernen, welcher dieser 12 Vorschläge war es denn jetzt eigentlich. Und es ist auch immer noch unklar, was heißt, wenn bei diesen 12 das ausgewählt wird, wenn ganz andere Substantive miteinander kombiniert werden, kann man da irgendwas draus Schluss folgern oder muss man das immer wieder neu lernen? Also muss man für immer 12 Vorschläge liefern oder kann man das irgendwann mal eindampfen, dass sich da wirklich Muster auch im Nutzerverhalten erkennen? Und wenn das passiert, dann kann man ja durchaus überlegen, ob man so einem Autorenzimmer eben, wie beim letzten Mal schon gesagt, nicht einfach ein weißes Blatt hinlegt, sondern schon Textvarianten und die mehr ins Redigieren kommen als ins Kreieren und da vielleicht auch eine sehr erfüllendere Aufgabe drin sehen. Es gibt sehr viele Leute, die ganz wunderbar und gerne redigieren, aber die total verhungern, wenn sie vor dem weißen Blatt Papier sitzen. Und es ist auch eine interessante Arbeitszeitung, dass manche Menschen sehr gerne einfach ins Archiv gehen und andere Leute sehr gerne formulieren. Und warum kann man diese Archivarbeit nicht einfach schon mal in eine Textform gießen, die dann zu redigieren ist? Also da sind auf verschiedenen eben so technische Generierungsprozesse drin, die sich durchaus lohnen, ausgebeutet zu werden. Und beim Film eben auch. Man will sich gerade bei Tom Cruise so von einer Flugzeugszene zur nächsten hangeln und dazwischen muss ein Dialog stattfinden. Wie gestaltet man ihn und mit welcher Hilfe? Technischer Hilfe. Und da gibt es ja Angebot.
Ich bin ja absolut davon überzeugt von der menschlichen Kreativität allein. Also ich glaube, dass das irgendwas simpler machen kann, wenn man jetzt vor Greenscreens dreht. Also wenn man jetzt alleine an das geht, was retuschiert werden muss oder so, dass das alles mit künstlichen Intelligenzen sinnvoller ist. Das ist so wie automatisierter Journalismus, wo man sagt, gut, jetzt kann man jemanden dahinsetzen, der ja alle Börsen Kurse abtippt und das dann in irgendeine Form gießt. Wenn das eine AI macht, wäre das besser, wenn man braucht eher jemand, der diese Börsen Kurse wirklich interpretieren kann, im Sinne von was droht uns in einem Monat. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass die menschliche Kreativität unersetzlich ist und auch die große Kunst nicht programmierbar ist. Und dass sich gerade auch das zeigt, dass man ja bemerkenswerterweise Tom Cruise nicht ersetzen kann. Und auch, dass es da keinen Nebenbruder gibt. Also es gibt schon auch einen Grund wohl, der sehr schwer zu finden ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich dieses je ne sais pas quoi, also irgendetwas, ein gewisses Etwas, das da vorhanden ist, das uns irgendwie so fasziniert, dass wir Tom Cruise auf der Leinwand sehen wollen. Denn man könnte ja auch einfach jemand anders nehmen. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man sagen kann, die Stunts kann nur Tom Cruise machen. Oder niemand kann so gut Texte auswendig lernen. All das ist ja nicht der Fall. Sondern Tom Cruise wäre eigentlich ersetzbar. Es gibt sogar Typen, die besser aussehen, jünger sind und was weiß ich. Aber trotzdem nimmt man Tom Cruise. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, bei einem guten künstlerischen Werk so, dass es dann doch so etwas wie eine Handschrift ist. Das ist doch auch der kreative Geist, der sich da ausgedrückt hat. Wenn der eine handwerkliche Unterstützung durch künstliche Intelligenzen bekommt, dann kann das sinnvoll sein. Und das kann auch hilfreich sein, das zu nutzen. Und man kann vielleicht dann produktiver sein. Aber ich glaube, dass man mit dieser Kompilation aus Versatzstücken und so am Ende doch nicht viel erreicht.
Ja, kann sein.
Also Stockfotos ja. Aber Stockfotos ist ja auch so quasi das Foto-Minimum. Was heißt Kleinkunst? Oder Kleinkraft. Also ein Fotograf will tolle Porträtaufnahmen oder so etwas machen oder tolle Landschaftsaufnahmen. Aber der reißt sich jetzt vielleicht nicht darum, einfach ein Stockfoto zu machen, wo zwei Gläser drauf abgebildet sind. Also auch das ist schwierig und erfordert Handwerk. Aber ich glaube, dass die künstlerische Schöpfungshöhe, da wo sie dann wirkliche Höhen erreicht, dass das der Punkt ist, wo die menschliche Kreativität, Gott sei Dank, über dem steht, was die Maschinen vermögen.
Genau. Vielleicht ist ja die Unterscheidung, die man anbringen muss, die große Kunst und eben der Kleinkram, der im Alltag so stattfindet. Denn manchmal hört man zum Einschlafen gerne Musik, von der man weiß, sie sollte einfach nur beruhigen. Gleichzeitig will man aber in ein Konzert gehen, um sich richtig in Wallung zu bringen. Und da ist es essenziell, dass da echte Menschen auf der Bühne stehen. Dieses ganze ABBA-Projekt und so weiter finde ich alles zum Scheitern verurteilt. Es ist wirklich nur eine Technik-Demonstration. Das macht man genau einmal mit. Und es muss dann aber auch ABBA sein. Und dann ist dieser Drops gelutscht. Dann haben dann ab dann einfach, also noch mal tausend Leute, die fünf Jahre lang arbeiten, wird es in diesem Gebiet da einfach nicht geben. Und in der Ansicht, ja, wandelt sich halt. Also die kreative Arbeit kann sich durchaus wandeln. Und ich denke zum Guten. Ich sehe da so ein gewisses Potenzial, gerade in dieser Textproduktion. Denn manchmal sind es wirklich nur Formulierungen, die zu schaffen sind. Und wir hatten das auch schon mal im privaten Rahmen so besprochen beim Essen. Mit anderen, die uns dann auch fragen, weil wir so Autoren sind, wo wir dann auch nochmal so runterdampfen mussten. Oder ich zumindest. Wenn ein Buch erst mal geschrieben ist, und es steht dann im Regal, und ein halbes Jahr später kommt es dann auf den Markt. In dem Moment, wo mit mir jemand über das Buch spricht, ist der Text für mich so fremd wie für den Leser. Weil das ist für mich auch schon wieder ein halbes Jahr her. Ich muss mich erinnern, was habe ich eigentlich geschrieben. Wenn ich es heute schreiben würde, würde ich es ganz anders schreiben. Und in deren Sicht hat man sowieso eine Entfremdung zwischen Werk und Autor. Wo dann so ein Textgenerator, der dazwischen hängt, auch nicht unbedingt eine neue qualitative Ebene einzieht, aber eine Entlastung in der Arbeit bieten kann. Und solche Sachen. Ich sehe da so ein bisschen... Ich finde, es hat gut angefangen mit automatischer Rechtschreibkorrektur. Und ich finde, Microsoft hat sich lange bemüht, mir andere Substantive vorzuschlagen, wenn ich eins verwende, und dann kommen so andere Ideen, und das sage ich alles nee und so. Aber in dieser allgemeinen Textgenerierung sehe ich noch Möglichkeiten, die es insgesamt besser und angenehmer für alle machen, für die Leser und für die Autoren. Aber mal sehen.
Es ist auch eine schöne Arbeit, an sich mit der Sprache zu spielen und zu formulieren und auch einen eigenen Stil zu haben. Man will ja nicht am Ende so abwaschbare Texte haben, wo man gar nicht mehr weiß, hat den jetzt der Stefan oder der Wolfgang geschrieben. Es sind jetzt funktionale Texte. Wenn jetzt nur jemand wissen will, wo finde ich den RSS-Feed, dann wäre gut, man könnte einfach der KI sagen, Antworten. Da braucht man auch jetzt nicht tollste Formulierungen für zu finden. Und du bist ja auch da jemand, der sehr kurz antwortet. Also man kann ja nicht den Vorwurf des Verschnörkelten machen.
Genau, das ist schon fast maschinenartig.
Ich mache dann ja noch so ein bisschen mehr. Aber sonst würde ich schon sagen, ist die Individualität, die mit einem Text verbunden ist, genau das eigentlich, was wir heute, wo wir so sehr von den Maschinen umgeben sind, brauchen. Und ich glaube, dass das auch am Ende ein Grund ist, warum Podcasts wie jetzt der unsere erfolgreich ist, dass man hier einzelne Menschen mit ihren sehr eigenen Stimmen, Gedanken und Formulierungen zu Wort kommen lässt, die auch ihre Menschlichkeit dadurch ausweisen, dass sie Fehler machen, dass sie irgendwo stocken und all das und nicht so funktionieren wie eine KI. Und das ist, glaube ich, wichtig, denn theoretisch könnten wir auch den Podcast aufnehmen. Und dann machen wir so ein Transkriptionsprogramm, das überarbeitet dann alles, was wir gesagt haben, überall, wo wir uns versprochen haben oder so. Das wird dann rausgenommen. Und dann bitten wir nochmal zwei Sprachassistenten, das einzusprechen, den Podcast, damit es dann absolut perfekt ist. Aber ich würde sagen, wir würden vermutlich einen großen Teil unseres Publikums verlieren.
Und das bringt uns doch wieder dazu, die Einzigartigkeit nochmal zu betonen. Und warum? Weil wir jetzt diese technische Konkurrenz da haben. In der Aufarbeitung von Alex läuft es auf die Pluante hinaus nochmal auf Deepmind. Das ist ja das Unternehmen, was Google damals gekauft hat in London. Und wo die Deepmind-Mitarbeiter gesagt haben, ihr könnt uns kaufen. Aber die Bedingung ist, ihr braucht dann ein Ethikrat. Und Google so, äh, wie was? Na ja, seitdem hat Google jedenfalls ein Ethikrat da irgendwie irgendwo versteckt. Und Deepmind kam jetzt mit GATO, G-A-T-O, um die Ecke. Und GATO macht all das, was ich vorher einzeln genannt hatte. Also Lambda macht Text. Dolly macht irgendwas mit Bildern. Und dann gibt es noch so verschiedene anderen Kram. Und das Anliegen von Deepmind ist, dass bei GATO das immer so ein bisschen zusammenzukombinieren. Und würde ich jetzt einfach mal sagen, auch in Schlussfolgerung unseres Gesprächs dazu, ein Spielzeug herzustellen, bei dem man einfach nicht genau weiß, was macht es eigentlich als nächstes, so wie man halt mit umgeht. Wozu führt es uns als nächstes? Soll alles noch nicht so besonders leistungsstark auf den jeweiligen Gebieten sein, aber eben schon gut zusammenwirken, was Text und Bild und überhaupt angeht. Also in der Ansicht scheint auf diesem Felde, und das kann man ja auch mal markieren, Corona einen gewissen Fortschritt gebracht zu haben, der anders wahrscheinlich anders und nicht so ergebnisstark, sage ich mal, gewesen wäre. Denn da sind sich doch alle irgendwie einig, dass so diese Corona-Zeit, die diese Fortschritte da jetzt gebracht hat.
Wir blicken zum Schluss noch in die Kryptoszene. Sarah Sendner hat für das Handelsblatt aufgeschrieben, inwieweit sich die Kryptoszene einmischt, jetzt in den US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf den kommenden. Und blickt auch nochmal zurück, was war eigentlich? Wie viel Geld kam aus der Kryptoszene für den vergangenen US-Wahlkampf zwischen Trump und Joe Biden?
Ist das eine Quizfrage? Da das Stadion in Los Angeles damals vor 20 Jahren 300 Millionen Euro Baukosten hatte und crypto.com jetzt für 700 Millionen die Namenrechte dort allein gekauft hat, würde ich sagen 300 Millionen. Nee, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen hochgegriffen oder denke ich schon wieder zu klein. Viel, viel Geld.
Nee, nee, ganz wenig. 500.000 Dollar.
500.000 Dollar? Ich dachte, die wollten auf der Großplatz.
Ja, es ist ganz verrückt. Und zwar heißt es hier, es sind nur noch fünf Monate bis zu den Zwischenwahlen in den USA und damit rücken die dem Land so wichtigen Parteispenden wieder an den Fokus des Interesses. Dieses Mal gibt es neue Protagonisten, denn vermögende Krypto-Unternehmer versuchen mit Rekordsummen politisch Einfluss zu nehmen mit rund 26,3 Millionen Dollar im Jahr 2021 und in den ersten drei Monaten 2022 überholen die Spender sogar die traditionell größten Gönner aus Pharmatech und Verteidigungsindustrie. Das berichtet der Finanzdienstleister Bloomberg. Das ist ein Anstieg aber jetzt von 5200 Prozent gegenüber demselben Zeitraum der vergangenen US-Präsidentschaftswahl, dem rund 500.000 Dollar aus der Krypto-Szene geflossen sind. Und jetzt wird es immer mehr, denn man hat natürlich Angst, dass man sein Vermögen, das man da macht oder sein Geschäftsmodell, das man sich gebaut hat, verlieren könnte. Es ist ja so, dass die Republikaner eigentlich der Krypto-Szene sehr aufgeschlossen sind und kryptofreundlich sind. Das hat aber dann nicht zur Folge, dass jetzt das ganze Geld zu den Republikanern fließt, sondern man kann ja gerade da Geld effektiv einsetzen, wo man Überzeugungsarbeit leisten muss, beziehungsweise wo man bestechen muss. Und deswegen bekommen überwiegend Demokraten Geld aus der Krypto-Szene, damit die nicht auf dumme Gedanken kommen. Elizabeth Warren ist ja der Krypto-Szene so ein Dorn im Auge. Ob sie jetzt da Geld erhalten hat, das ist jetzt hier dem nicht zu entnehmen. Aber einige andere Demokraten haben doch ganz stattliche Summen bekommen. Und zum Beispiel die Kandidatin Arika Rhodes, kenne ich nicht, oder Rhodes, die hat also enorme Summen bekommen. Und einige andere auch. Weiterhin heißt es dann, es gibt dann so Events, die ausgerichtet werden. Die größte Kryptobörse Coinbase veranstaltete Ende März. Ein Spendenevent für den demokratischen Mehrheitsführer Chuck Schumer. Also auch der wird dann bedacht. Und naja, es geht jetzt eigentlich erst so richtig los. Manche Krypto-Anhänger haben auch noch ganz andere Ambitionen. Also da ist zum Beispiel der Branchenprimus Bankman Freed. Da wird angekündigt, wir könnten da mal mit 100 Millionen Dollar unterstützen. Und die wollen auf keinen Fall Trump haben. Sollte Trump nochmal antreten, würde man für die Gegenkampagne sogar vielleicht eine Milliarde in die Hand nehmen. Also man hat da doch eine ganz eigenartige Auffassung mitunter, was man haben will und wen man nicht haben will. Jedenfalls stellt sich die Frage, ob das dann auch wirklich so weitergeht mit diesen Spenden. Denn natürlich sind die Portfolios sehr geschrumpft jetzt, dieser ganzen Crypto-Pros. Das bleibt abzuwarten. Aber wenn ich das hier so lese, würde ich mal sagen, ein Verbot oder auch nur eine harsche Regulierung von amerikanischer Seite des Kryptomarks wird nicht zu erwarten sein.
Jo, davon ist ja mal wohl auszugehen. Es ist einfach zu viel Geld. Jetzt wo du die Beträge genannt hast, Google, die haben ja eigentlich immer diesen angeführt, die Liste. Und lagen dann auch so bei 30, 40 Millionen. Weil es sind ja immer noch direkte Unterstützungen, die ja auch ordentlich protokolliert werden müssen. Da geht man natürlich nicht in die hunderten Millionen. Aber im Umfeld ja dann schon diese Superpacks, die sich da bilden, also die offen sind, einfach für alle Unterstützung. Obwohl man auch nicht genau weiß, wie man das jetzt braucht.
Genau, das haben die auch sehr für sich jetzt erkannt.
Das wird da auch drin geschildert. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Der nächste Präsidentschaftswahlkampf, da das jetzt immer alles auf Messers Schneide ist und so, da geht es ja dann wirklich richtig zur Sache. Gut, damit ist der Salon beschlossen. Alle Texte sind besprochen. Weitere wichtige Texte gab es nicht. Nein, doch. Weist uns gerne weiter auf Kram hin. Ein Buch haben wir aber noch nicht fürs nächste Mal. Wir wissen nur schon, wenn Precht und Wälzer dann da sind, werden wir das lesen im September.
Das müssen wir machen, bzw. Oktober. Ich glaube, es kommt dann ganz Ende September. Wir werden es dann im Salon natürlich besprechen. Ganz gelassen werden wir das tun, ohne zu Hyperventilieren. Gestern bebte schon Twitter. Und das Schöne ist, dass wir uns schon sehr über Precht und Wälzer mokiert haben und dass wir mitunter aber auch schon mal einige Aspekte gelobt haben. Das heißt, wir können da sehr unbefangen reingehen. Und das Einzige, was uns interessieren wird, ist, überzeugen die Argumente, ja oder nein. Alles andere, wer da von welcher Seite aus applaudiert und macht und tut, das ist für mich nicht kriegsentscheidend.
Ganz genau. Wir werden ja nicht nur das Cover lesen, so wie gestern alle, sondern wir werden ja den Text da lesen und auf die Probe stellen.
Und wir wissen ja, wenn nur Covers oder so gelesen werden oder nur...
Dann geht es schief...
.Baggardsberichte und so, das ist nicht so gut.
Genau, wenn nur die Baggardsberichte gelesen werden.
Wir machen was ganz Abseitiges, wir lesen das Buch.
Ja, wir lesen einfach Bücher. Unglaublich. Gut, dann sehen wir uns Ende Juli wieder. Das zweite Halbjahr ist damit eröffnet. Und alle, die jetzt schon Urlaub haben, wünschen wir einen schönen Urlaub.
Und wir gehen natürlich nicht in die Sommerpause. Nein, darauf legen wir werde. Also das finde ich ja ganz furchtbar. Wir sind hier nicht im alten Fernsehen mit Sommerpause oder so. Es wird gesendet, egal was ist. Und deswegen sehen wir uns dann wieder. Bis dann.
Richtig. Wir bleiben dem Rhythmus treu.